Oh, was ist denn hier? Warum ist das jetzt nicht richtig?
Warum geht das nicht? Anzeige ist raus.
Ich habe an der Verlängerung wiederum gewackelt.
Moin.
Pass mal auf, Leute, ich werde jetzt meine Audio-Quality increasen.
Moment.
So, increased Audio-Quality am Start.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man den Unterschied hört.
Ich hoffe, jetzt ist es besser.
Oh, gut.
Sag sei Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscriptions hier.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Ich mache mal kurz mein 8-Schlinox an.
By the way.
Dann kommt ein neues Video, wenn ich aufgenommen habe.
Ich habe noch nicht aufgenommen.
Und wir haben mal Package-Updates.
Und ich muss hier mal meine Jacke zumachen, weil ansonsten schleift das Kabel so blöd an dem Reißverschluss.
Macht komische Geräusche.
Aber deswegen wird es zu warm, wenn ich zumache.
Das ist der Sack.
Da noch.
Was mache ich denn jetzt?
Ja, es wird bestimmt auch gleich wieder kühler.
Also ich bin ja gerade wieder vom Rennen gekommen, so vor Viertelstunde.
Da ist einem noch ziemlich warm.
Und Leute, ich habe heute Morgen im Bett nach dem Aufstehen, habe ich auf YouTube geguckt, was mir für Videos empfohlen wurden.
Und da wurde mir ein Video empfohlen.
How not to code?
Und da regt sich einer auf über irgendwelche Command Line USB Tools von Intel.
Da muss ich euch gleich mal was daraus zeigen.
Das ist so schlecht.
Das habe ich auch nicht gesehen.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass Intel sowas zusammenprogrammiert.
Du schreibst, also AP1, Chatge, AP1 ist Zwischenprüfung, richtig?
Ich finde es ja witzig, dass die Zwischenprüfung mittlerweile Abschlussprüfung 1 heißt.
IHK Benahmung on point, Alter.
Könnte mir fast denken, Microsoft hat das benannt.
Ja, ich wollte mal kurz noch Stats gucken.
Heute war ich nämlich gefühlt ziemlich schnell unterwegs und es ging eigentlich ohne, ohne DATGIT zu sein.
Ja, ey, heute war nicht schlecht.
Ich bin heute nur 5 Kilometer gerannt, aber 5,36 pro Kilometer.
Das ist einfach mal 40 Sekunden schneller.
Bekomme Connect Beta Tester.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Dann war 40 Sekunden schneller als sonst.
Aber sonst war ich ja auch gechillt.
Heute war schnell.
Es war zwar anstrengend.
Aber nicht so, dass ich jetzt umgefallen wäre.
Meinsch ganz nice.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken, was das Ding meint.
Es ist zu kalt.
Nee, es war 5,5 Grad, fast 6 Grad heute Morgen.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was die Uhr meint, was meine Performance sagt.
Aha, heute, heute sagt sie, meine Performance ist plus 3, plus 2, plus 1.
Immerhin, nice.
High Performance Grindset Mindset.
Durchschnittliche Geschwindigkeit 56.
Besser Kilometer 4,46.
Also heute war wirklich sehr zackig, muss ich sagen.
Man sieht witzigerweise auch genau dort, wo es den Berg runter geht.
Das ist lustig.
Ich kann es euch jetzt nicht zeigen, aber das zeichnet ja die Herzfrequenz auf.
Und das ist immer so um, ja, immer so um 160, 164, 165.
Und also zwischendurch geht es auch mal ein bisschen weiter hoch.
Teilweise über 170.
Und Maximum war 177.
Aber es geht zweimal den Berg runter.
Und dann nochmal so ein bisschen leicht den Berg runter.
Und davor geht es natürlich den Berg hoch, ja.
Und man sieht so richtig, ohne dass man das Profil kennt, wo das ist.
Man sieht so gleich, es geht halt runter von 165 auf, keine Ahnung, 140.
Dann geht es nämlich den Berg wieder hoch und dann instant wieder 165 runter, 140.
Also man kann das Profil von der Runde genau erkennen anhand von der Herzfrequenz fast schon.
Aber heute ging echt zackig.
Und lief es auch.
Wisst ihr, es gibt manchmal so Tage, das machen wir mal richtig update hier.
Es gibt manchmal so Tage, da merkst du schon beim Losrennen, irgendwie es sackt, kommst nicht vorwärts.
Dann hast du Tage, wo du denkst, ey, heute merkst du die Beine gar nicht so easy.
Dann geht es so ein Mittel schnell, aber dafür ziemlich lang.
Und dann hast du so...
Tage, da rennst du schon schnell los
und merkst an der Stelle, wo du
normalerweise denkst, so boah ey,
bist du aber ein bisschen schnell gestartet, easy, geht ohne
Probleme. Und das war heute
Sonntag. Da hab ich mir gedacht,
okay, wenn es nach dem ersten
Kilometer bei der Geschwindigkeit immer noch easy
ist, rennst du halt einfach weiter in der
Geschwindigkeit. Ja, war da ein bisschen
anstrengend, aber ging ganz gut.
Reboot. Hab keine Ahnung
von Papp-UML. Also
ganz ehrlich,
ich kann das aus dem Kopf auch nicht.
Und ich muss euch auch ehrlich sagen,
Chatge, mal die Frage an euch, die in der
Softwareentwicklung hauptberuflich arbeiten. Ich meine,
ich bin ja kein, ich programmier zwar gerne
und mach auch die ein oder anderen
kleinen Tools auf der Arbeit und bin da am Skripten
und Automatisieren, aber ich bin ja kein hauptberuflicher Anwendungsentwickler.
Mal die Frage an die Leute,
die hauptberufliche Anwendungsentwickler sind oder
mit hauptberuflichen Anwendungsentwicklern zusammenarbeiten.
Macht ihr
UML-Diagramme oder
Programmablaufpläne irgendwie?
Also ich hab das
gefühlt noch nie gesehen.
Also das höchste der Gefühle
an UML-Diagrammen, was ich bisher
gesehen hab, ist, wenn irgendwelche
IDEs aus den schon vorhandenen Klassen
automatisch
irgendwas
generaten.
Ansonsten nicht.
Kann man eigentlich in OBS,
sowas wie Ctrl-M oder so,
kann man in OBS einen
Hotkey
Mute
Gibt es einen Mute-Hotknie?
Ein Hotknie, genau.
Gibt es einen Mute-Hotknie irgendwo?
Mute?
Ah!
Microphone Mute.
Push to Mute.
Ctrl-M?
Ah ne, das ist ja MonkaS schon.
Ctrl-Komma, Ctrl-Komma ist gut.
Okay, Ctrl-Komma?
Äh.
Macht nix, oder?
Macht nix. Ist dem vollkommen
egal.
Was hab ich jetzt falsch
gemacht? Mute.
Ah ne, das ist Push.
Push to Mute.
Aber Ctrl-Komma Mute.
Ctrl-Punkt.
Funzt aber nicht, oder?
Funzt.
So, muted.
Wieder unmuted, okay.
Gut.
Wobei, Ctrl-Punkt?
Ctrl-Komma? Braucht man das
ab und zu mal bei irgendwas?
Mir fällt jetzt zwar nix ein. Nicht, dass ich mich aus Versehen mute.
Und alle fragen sich, warum hört man mich nicht mehr.
Also Komma ist Mute, ne?
Warum gibt es nicht, drücke den gleichen
Knopf zweimal für Mute,
Unmute. Und es wäre
sehr nice, wenn das Ding irgendwie ne Audio-Bestätigung
machen könnte, wenn
es, kann es ne Audio-Bestätigung machen,
wenn es Mute ist? Ne, oder?
Follow.
Also das sind die Input-Sourcen.
Ja, dann müsste ich das über irgendwelche
Windows-Sachen machen.
Weil das wäre nice. So, also.
Ihr macht alle
keinen UML.
Content is no longer available.
Geht das auch, wenn ich auf dem zweiten Bildschirm bin?
Ne.
Muss hier sein. Ich fand's das nicht.
Na gut.
So. Hm. Ja.
Der Content is not not available.
Wer weiß, was Discord da wieder für
komische Dinger macht.
Ja, das ist aber normal. Da musst du dich dran gewöhnen,
dass die IHK-Prüfungen
zum größten Teil nicht dadurch
bestanden werden, weil du krasses
Know-How hast,
sondern weil du verstehst, was die wissen wollen.
Also die Herausforderung
einer Abschlussprüfung ist eindeutig,
zu verstehen, wie die IHK Fragen
stellt und die Fragen so zu beantworten,
wie es die IHK hören will. Nicht,
wie das technisch am besten wäre,
oder nicht, dass du irgendwie glänzen kannst
mit deinen krassen Skills oder so.
Nein, es geht in der Abschlussprüfung rein darum,
zu verstehen, was die IHK
wissen will und es genauso zu beantworten,
wie die IHK es hören will.
Nicht, ob das richtig ist,
oder ob das ist eigentlich vollkommen...
...ist eigentlich vollkommen...
...vollkommen egal.
Würdest du sagen, du hast sie zu 50% bestanden?
Das heißt, du meinst, du hast gerade
50% geschafft, oder du hast...
...du bist dir zu 50%
sicher, sie bestanden zu haben?
Übers Essen? Na ja, heute
ist...ja, was ist denn heute?
Dankeschön, wenn ihr es habt. Was ist heute?
Es ist nicht Nudeln mit Lachs heute angesagt.
Frühstückschamp.
Pepo Croissant.
Hatten wir nicht noch irgendwie so einen...
Wo ist denn mein Baguette?
Ach, hier.
Okay. Notifications.
Was ist das?
Ah ja, was ich da nicht alles habe.
So.
Hat das jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet?
Ich glaube schon. Das hat geupdatet.
Das ist durch. Okay, alles gut.
Ja, du schaffst das schon.
Wie gesagt, das Wichtige bei der IHK
Abschlussprüfung und auch bei der Zwischenprüfung
ist zu verstehen, was die wissen wollen
und wie die fragen. Nicht so sehr,
dass du die krassen Skills hast, weil
die Fragen an sich, wenn man weiß, was die wissen will,
meistens easy as fuck.
Du verstehst das bloß oftmals nicht.
Ich meine, seriously. Ein Großteil der IHK
Abschlussprüfung besteht aus so
bescheuerten Fragen wie
Sie sind Mitarbeiter im
Administrationsteam der Alligator GmbH.
Ihr Chef
möchte von Ihnen eine Zuordnung
der folgenden Punkte. Und dann kriegst du dann
so eine Liste. Ordnen Sie zu.
Die Rettungskette.
Krankenwagen
rufen. Sich selbst in Sicherheit bringen.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das ging.
Was war
die Rettungskette?
Eigenschutz.
Krankenwagen rufen.
Keine Ahnung.
Was weiß ich?
Das weiß ich genau einmal
im Jahr, wenn ich diese Multiple Choice
Dinger ausfüllen muss.
Weil das gibt es nicht nur in der IHK
Prüfung. Das gibt es witzigerweise auch
bei uns jedes Jahr.
Jedes Jahr muss jeder Mitarbeiter so eine
Gefahren-Dingsbums
Prüfung machen.
Was passiert bei Feueralarm?
Und wie ist die Rettungskette?
Und das weiß ich genau einmal
im Jahr, wenn ich
diesen komischen Multiple Choice Test machen muss.
Der Witz ist ja auch,
du kannst dabei
nicht failen.
Du kannst es
ausfüllen, falsch machen.
Ausfüllen, falsch machen, ausfüllen.
Wenn du es dann immer noch nicht
geschafft hast, zumal du dann
eigentlich schon durch puren Zufall
statistisch gesehen richtig
liegst, aber egal.
Und wenn du es dann nicht geschafft hast,
dann klickst du es einfach nochmal von vorne durch.
Du kannst es nicht
bestehen, im Endeffekt, diese Sicherheitsunterweisung.
Oder generell diese
jährlichen Tests, die man da
macht. Du kannst sie so oft machen, wie du willst.
Und irgendwann
wirst du es schon bestehen. Und die Fragen sind immer die
gleichen. Du kannst sie theoretisch
sogar Screenshots machen und
das nächstes Jahr genauso ausfüllen.
Eigentlich komplett bescheuert.
Das ist eine typische
IHK-Formulierung.
Was ist ein Videotutorial?
Videotutorials sind elektronische
Versionen von Gebrauchsanleitungen.
Die Videos können dann auf einer
lokalen Datenablage und
oder online von der Zielperson
angeschaut werden. Das ist so eine typische
IHK-Formulierung.
Das ist ja streng genommen nicht falsch.
Das ist ja nur
wirklich verkehrt.
So Leute, ich wollte euch mal was zeigen. Ich habe heute Morgen ein Video
gesehen auf YouTube.
Ich will euch nur einen Ausschnitt
daraus zeigen. Wir gucken uns das Ganze an.
Aber das hat mich mal schockiert,
was Intel da so zusammenprogrammiert.
Ich muss nochmal kurz gucken, wie das heißt.
Hier.
Ich zeige euch nochmal einen Ausschnitt.
How to not code.
Irgendwas in Intel.
Hier.
So.
Intel Thunderbolt Utilities.
Haltet euch mal fest.
Das ist in C programmiert.
Aber der Typ, der das programmiert hat,
also das ist nicht der, der reviewt das nur.
Der Typ, der das programmiert hat,
oder der Praktikant von Intel, der das programmiert hat,
der hatte keinen Bock auf C.
Das werdet ihr gleich sehen.
Und zwar, seht ihr das hier?
Also erstmal finde ich übrigens
sehr nice Schriftart, die der Kerl hier hat.
Seht ihr das hier?
Fällt euch da was auf?
Intel macht
Intel macht Shell in C.
Weil sie nicht wissen, wie es in C funktioniert.
Und das geht noch so weiter.
Das geht noch so weiter.
Das wurde mir heute Morgen empfohlen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum YouTube
gedacht hat, ich soll das jetzt gucken.
Ja, aber Intel macht...
Ja, der lässt sich jetzt hier ein bisschen
drüber aus.
Ja, der Rest ist auch nicht besser, aber...
Guck hier. Guck mal hier.
Guck mal.
Sudo Bash minus C.
Ich mein, man fragt sich
ernsthaft, ja? Man fragt sich
ernsthaft, warum ist das
in C programmiert, wenn das
einfach nur irgendwelche Calls zu
Bash macht? Warum haben sie nicht
gleich ein Bash-Tool da drum... Ja gut,
ich kann mir vorstellen, warum sie nicht gleich ein Bash-Tool
da drum herum gebaut haben.
Weil sie paar Kernelfunktionen brauchen in C.
Und das wollen sie aufrufen. Ich mein, ganz ehrlich,
Ich mein, ganz ehrlich,
ich würde das auch machen, wenn ich
irgendwas basteln will, was einfach nur
schnell geht und nur ich
verwende oder so, ja?
So nach dem Motto, ey, ich muss das
in irgendeiner Low-Level-Sprache machen, weil
ich Kernelfunktionen aufrufen muss, aber hab
eigentlich gar keinen Bock, den Rest ordentlich zu machen.
Okay, aber das ist halt echt
weirdchamp.
Wisst ihr, was mir da an der Stelle gerade auffällt?
Warum...
Warum speicherallocaten
die hier eigentlich?
Was? Moment, Moment...
Achso!
Die returnen dann
nen Pointer mit der
mit der Ausgabe...
Moment, die returnen nen Pointer
mit der Ausgabe von sudo bash-c
und dann command.
Das ist, ja, das ist also wirklich
Bash-Script in C gerappt.
Also keine Ahnung, was mit
Intel abging. Also muss ich euch mal
zeigen, das ist echt weird.
Man könnte
ja einfach sagen, ey,
es ist ja nicht so, als könnte man das nicht auch so
in C machen. Aber das ist halt,
das ist halt...
Warum? Ich hab's bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen,
warum die das überhaupt in C gemacht haben.
Wie gesagt, ich vermute, weil sie irgendwelche Kernelfunktionen
aufrufen wollen.
Ja, aber das fand ich echt grausam.
Das Ding ist halt, da kannst du wahrscheinlich,
da brauchst du noch, da muss doch nicht
mal irgendwo was overflowen in C,
sondern
da kannst du wahrscheinlich durch pure Text-Eingabe
dann irgendwas
kaputt machen.
Ja gut, aber was willst du großartig machen
in C, wenn du irgendeinen
String returnen willst, oder irgendwelche
also...
Ja, aber das ist
das ist ja normal, das macht FFmpeg ja auch
nicht anders.
Wenn du bei FFmpeg ein Video öffnest,
kriegst du auch einen Context-Pointer
und den musst du am Ende selbst
freeen, das ist halt in C so.
Das willst du machen, ja.
Hier sagst du, du kannst dich nicht auf
den Aufrufer verlassen und hier, man soll es
dem Aufrufer überlassen, oder wie? Hä?
Ich mein,
es geht da gar nicht anders.
Der Aufrufer muss immer
freeen, solange
du es nicht nur intern brauchst.
Stimmt, eigentlich
benutzen die nur einen Shell-Rapper
von C nach C, warum auch immer.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich,
was du meinst.
Du, ach,
du meinst, dass da, ach so,
okay,
jetzt hab ich's verstanden, ja, das stimmt,
da geb ich dir recht. Du meinst, dass das quasi nicht
intern allocated und den Pointer zurückgibt,
sondern, dass du den Pointer als
Parameter haben willst,
sodass du quasi als Aufrufer weißt,
du musst das allocaten und dementsprechend
denkst du daran, da später auch wieder zu freeen.
Ja, ja, gut, das stimmt.
Das macht übrigens FFmpeg tatsächlich so, ja.
In FFmpeg
rufst du dann sowas auf wie
Alloc Context, den Context
übergibst du dann in Open Input,
und Open, aber Open Input
kann ihn auch freeen, weil FFmpeg teilweise
ein bisschen undurchsichtig ist,
aber das ist so, wie du es, wie du schreibst, ja.
Keyprint FAP,
genau. Wer kennt sie nicht?
So.
Bisschen,
bisschen Hackermans
Hintergrund, Moment, nicht das.
C-Matrix, C.
Ist doch safe, so, auch entstanden,
irgendwo hat das schnell zusammengetackert und dachte nie, dass es ein Produkt
Das stimmt schon,
aber das auf Github zu veröffentlichen
Open Source unter Intel
als irgendwelche USB-Thunderbolt-Utils
ohne, dass das irgendjemand
sich mal angeguckt hat, gut, es könnte
natürlich auch sein, dass sich das jemand angeguckt hat
und die gesagt haben, alter, das können wir nicht veröffentlichen
und dann wirklich irgendein Management-Typ
gekommen ist und hat gesagt, alter, haben wir jetzt
haben wir jetzt keine Zeit für, hau raus.
Wir müssen das nächste
machen, hau raus den Kram.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was es geben müsste
für Github-Comets
oder für Github-Projekte?
Es gibt doch, es gibt doch so
also, wenn du Drehbuchautor
bist oder Regisseur oder sowas, ja
und der Film so scheiße
ist oder dir die Leute so
viel reinreden, dass du nichts mehr damit zu tun
haben willst, dann kannst du dich ja entweder
löschen lassen aus den Credits oder
irgend so ein Pseudonym eintragen in den
Credits, dass niemand weiß, dass du was damit
zu tun hattest. Sowas bräuchte es
eigentlich für Github auch.
Wenn du quasi in Anführungszeichen gezwungen
wirst, irgendwas zu veröffentlichen, obwohl
du eigentlich nicht willst, dass dein Name
damit in Verbindung gebracht wird,
dann müsste es auch möglich sein, so irgendwie
nachträglich das so
genau in so ein Pseudonym zu
ersetzen. Moin.
Jaja, aber das wär nice.
Ja, kannst du machen.
Das ist genauso, wie wir das gemacht haben mit
der WebRTC-Geschichte. Da haben wir auch
Low-Level-Sachen in Rust
beziehungsweise Rust mit C-Interface
gemacht und haben es von C-Sharp aus aufgerufen.
Ich glaube, dazu mussten die
Entwickler manchmal outsourcen.
Das kriegen die auch so hin.
War das nicht auch jemand von Intel,
wo Linus das letzte Mal wieder
gerantet hat, dass er immer den gleichen
Shit committen würde und
es langsam nicht mehr sehen kann?
Ja, ich hoffe, da machen sie auch Bash-Aufrufe.
Bash integriert, Shell integriert
in Intel-CPUs demnächst.
Ja, aber da hab ich mir gedacht, das muss
ich euch mal zeigen.
Ganz besonders speziell, was
Intel da programmiert hat.
Leute, findet ihr, dass mein Sound heute
besser klingt als sonst?
Wie du ein legendäres E-Theme in
Last Epoch herstellst. Oh, das wollte ich auch
spielen. Einfach einmal
durch und gut ist.
Dann ist es auch gut. Ist auch gut, wenn es
nicht schlechter klingt. Hört sich an wie immer.
Ich glaube, man hört es so im direkten
Vergleich.
Ein Ticken besser müsste es sein.
Was macht
Fireship da?
JavaScript.
Wartet lieber 1-2 Wochen, die Server brennen komplett.
Ja, aber es ist doch besonders nice spielen,
wenn sie neu sind zu spielen, oder?
Also außer manche, aber so
Multiplayer-Sachen sind doch...
Was hat man denn sonst noch hier?
Kronk ist einfach immer am Start.
Der war schon
am Start auf YouTube, als ich angefangen habe
und ist einfach immer noch da.
Der Bahn-Bubble hört
auf!
Jetzt ist es aber vorbei.
Also die Video-Empfehlungen
sind ja wieder
ganz toll.
Oh nein, wir kriegen Weeb-Musik-Empfehlungen,
weil ich einmal angemacht habe.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich persönlich habe nie viel Kronk
geguckt, aber ich finde es
nice, dass der immer noch am Start ist.
YouTube wäre nicht mal das gleiche ohne Kronk.
Warte mal, ich habe schon Updates
gemacht. Ja, Chatkin, lass uns
doch mal kurz gucken, was auf GitHub getrendet ist
diese Woche. Okay.
AI. Wir überspringen wieder alles, was AI ist.
AI, AI, AI.
Ne. Was?
An extremely fast Python
Package Installer. Okay, das ist quasi
Pip in Rust.
Was haltet ihr von
TinyTan and Tiny...
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist.
Ja, das ist quasi Pip in Rust.
Jetzt ist
die Frage, ne?
Warum macht man
UV-Pip? Egal.
Also, jetzt ist die Frage,
ist das wirklich nice?
Oder
ist das ein typischer Fall dessen, was ich
ja immer anspreche bei Rust-Projekten?
Die Rust-Community löst Probleme, die es
nicht gibt. Das kann ich nicht richtig
einschätzen, weil ich zu wenig Python
Zeug mach.
Du hast zum ersten Mal das Gefühl, dass dein Pop-Schutz
funktioniert? Ja, ich habe heute mein Mikrofon
auch anders angeschlossen. Nicht mal über
diese kaputte Verlängerung, sondern direkt am
Audio-Interface.
Vielleicht liegt das auch daran.
Gepoppt. Einmal
gepoppt, niemals gestoppt. Oder wie war
das bei Pringles? Ne, Moment.
War das nicht umgedreht?
Einmal
geploppt? Ach, was
weiß ich.
Gibt's das überhaupt noch, das Zeug?
Ewig nicht mehr gefuttert.
Ja,
was trenne denn sonst noch? Also hier, UV.
Astral.sh
Okay.
Wird alles in Rust neu.
Blazingly fast gemacht.
Aha.
Style.
Windows 11 in schlank.
Heißt das Windows 11
um das ganze Telemetrie-Kram?
Habe ich noch nie
gehört.
Was ist das?
Scripts to build a trimmed down
Windows 11 Image.
Okay.
Aber was hat man davon jetzt?
Der Clipchamp wurde
removed. Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht
so, als würden diese Apps so super viel verbrauchen.
Ich meine, ja, es ist doof, dass sie überhaupt
anhandmäßig dabei sind, das verstehe ich schon.
Aber
es ist jetzt so, als fände ich das super
schrecklich, dass die
da sind. Zumal man die, glaube ich, sogar theoretisch
Clipchamp
aninstallen könnte, oder?
Bam, Clipchamp ist weg.
Ne, Clipchamp lässt sich nicht an- ah doch.
Ist das jetzt weg?
Ja, guck, weg ist er, der Clipchamp.
Ja, vom Namen her hätte es von mir sein können.
Deswegen bin ich seltsam, dass es den
Clipchamp uninstallt.
Ne, habe ich schon, also,
habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Sehe ich den Sinn auch nur
semi drinnen?
So, AI, AI,
äh, go
modern download manager
Ein Download Manager
in Flutter.
Okay. Ist das quasi
der neue JDownloader,
oder was?
Natürlich, natürlich lädt man damit nur
ISO-Images runter.
Sieht halt auf dem Desktop schon wieder aus, wie so eine gammelige
Material Design Android Anwendung.
Aber ist klar,
es ist auch Flutter.
Moment, es ist Go plus
Flutter. Also wahrscheinlich
das Frontend in
Flutter und Dart und alles
was irgendwie, wo man was für braucht,
Go.
Das finde ich aber insofern interessant.
Wie macht man denn?
Wie interfacet man denn?
Oder, äh,
wie interopt man denn?
Go und Flutter.
Weiß das jemand, ist das easy, oder muss man das
auch, ne, das muss man über
über C-Interfaces
machen, ne?
Das ist
auch weirdchamp, warum man das
über irgendwelche FFI
C-Interface Sachen machen muss.
Warum gibt es keine bessere
Integration zwischen Flutter und Go?
Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht.
Und welche Plattform
unterstützt das?
Goop Speed.
HTTP, BitTorrent.
Achso.
Verschiedene Protokolle meinen die damit.
Ich dachte, unterstützt verschiedene
Plattformen, also kannst du dann auch von
Pornhub oder keine Ahnung
die Sachen mit der URL runterladen, aber das
geht anscheinend nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, wann habe ich
zuletzt einen Download Manager verwendet?
Das ist wohl
wahr, ja.
Da hatte ich auch schon öfters Probleme mit.
Es geht ja in der Regel,
aber es ist lahm.
Und was richtig lahm
ist, ist
von anderen Sprachen in Go
rein callen. Von Go
woanders hin callen ist auch lahm, aber
richtig lahm ist von C nach
Go. Von Go nach C
ist auch langsam, aber von C nach Go ist
noch langsamer.
So.
Haben wir denn sonst noch hier schönes
Weep-Musik wieder?
Was trennt er denn sonst noch?
AI
AI AI
Next Generation
Face Swapper and Enhancer
What?
Mein Face ist geswappt. In your face.
China-Chinesen-Kram?
Chat GPT und WeChat,
definitiv China-Chinesen-Kram.
Proxy-Kram,
auch China-Chinesen-Zeug.
AI
YOLO World, das ist Image Detection.
Glaube ich.
Nee, Object Detection.
Und China-Chinesen-Kram.
Alles klar. Also diese Woche
interessiert mich nichts von dem, was trennt.
Absolut gar nix.
Max arbeitet ihr auf der Arbeit auch
Alter, Hustenstelz.
Max arbeitet ihr auf der Arbeit eigentlich
auch agil, aber richtig.
Wir skalieren schon diagonal.
Ich muss mal gucken kurz im Handy.
Ob nächste Woche wieder
Sprint ist oder nicht.
Lass mich mal kurz checken.
Ich glaube, es war diese Woche Sprint.
Nächste Woche ist kein Sprint.
Lass mich mal schauen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Dienstag.
Daily Scrum.
Ja, das ist ja nicht.
Ach nee.
Nächste Woche habe ich Termin mit meinem Chef wieder.
Das heißt, es ist die Woche, wo kein Sprint ist.
Nächste Woche, also dann
quasi übernächste Woche, wenn man genau ist,
ist dann wieder Sprint.
Also quasi am 5.
März
wird wieder gesprintet.
Hier.
Produktteam Sprint Review.
Geht los. 9.30 Uhr.
Daily Sprint.
Produktteam Sprint
Retrospektive.
Produktteam Sprint Planning.
Produktteam
Jour Fix.
Da ist ja wieder sowas von
agil.
In zwei Wochen Dienstag.
Da mach ich jetzt
jetzt seriously. Macht ihr safe? Nee.
Zum Ernsthaft.
Wisst ihr, was ich an dem Tag mach?
Also nicht nächste Woche,
übernächste Woche Dienstag.
Was ich den ganzen Tag mache? Ich mache nix.
Ich fange an. Also ich fahre morgens
dann wahrscheinlich nach Frankfurt.
So. 9.30 Uhr geht's los.
Sprint Review.
10 Uhr.
Das geht ja schon eineinhalb Stunden Sprint Review.
10 Uhr ist eigentlich
unser Team Daily. Das ist dazwischen Paralleltermin.
Mal gucken, ob ich hingehe. Dann
geht's direkt im Anschluss weiter. 11 Uhr
Sprint Retrospektive.
Dann wird gefuttert. Dann geht's direkt
weiter im Anschluss. Ah okay.
Nicht direkt. Also es geht
11 Uhr bis 12.30 Uhr Sprint Retrospektive.
Dann gehe ich was futtern.
Und dann geht's
14 Uhr weiter.
Nee.
Ja. 14.30 Uhr.
Weiter Sprint Planning.
Zwei Stunden bis 16.30 Uhr.
Aber da haue ich meistens schon
dann ab. Da bin ich nicht
bis zum Schluss dabei. Das sehe ich nicht.
So. Paralleltermin. Hätte ich dann 14.30 Uhr
noch irgendeinen Sure-Fix
anderer Service?
Jaja. Ist klar. Das
easy. Da wird nix gemacht.
Da wird nix gemacht den ganzen Tag
nächste Woche. Also übernächste Woche Dienstag.
Aber ich denke mir so.
Ich finde es zwar nicht geil.
Wenn die Firma das so will.
Meinetwegen.
Warum bist du beim Planning nicht dabei?
Doch. Bin ich doch. Habe ich doch gerade vorgelesen.
Planning ist.
Das habe ich doch gerade gesagt.
Ach so. Du meinst, dass ich da meist.
Ach das meinst du. Ja doch doch. Da bin ich dabei.
Aber ich haue dann meistens ab.
Weil das bis 16.30 Uhr geht.
Und ich haue entweder 15 Uhr oder 16 Uhr
schon ab von der Arbeit in Frankfurt.
Da hocke ich mich dann noch
mit dem Handy. Da ziehe ich das Headset auf.
Da hocke ich mich noch im Zug rein.
Und höre da ein bisschen zu.
Und sage vielleicht die eine oder andere Sache was.
Also ich kann dann quasi weiter mieten im Zug.
Da muss ich ja nicht wirklich vor Ort hocken.
Und das schöne ist.
Dadurch kann ich die Heimfahrt theoretisch
auch noch abrechnen als Remote Arbeit.
Dann ist es ja auch.
Just for fun mache ich das nicht.
Wenn unser Planning ist
kann man in der Kantine
for free essen.
Das ist wenigstens ein bisschen anders.
Hinzugehen.
Also in unserer Kantine kann man nie for free essen.
Aber unsere Kantine ist so krass subventioniert.
Das du dort.
Ich habe letztens gefuttert.
Also letztens ist schon Monate her.
Ich war noch nicht so oft in der Kantine.
Obwohl die nicht schlecht ist.
Ich habe letztens gefuttert.
Salat bis oben hin voll.
Dann einmal Hauptspeise.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr was das war.
Irgendwie Nudeln oder Pizza oder irgendwas.
Hauptspeise.
Trinken plus Nachtisch.
Für 6,30 Euro.
Das ist halt massive billig.
Dafür.
Für 6,30 hast du sogar vor Jahren
nur irgendwie
Nudeln mit Hähnchen beim Asia Laden
um die Ecke gekriegt.
Ohne trinken ohne alles.
Also unsere Kantine ist wirklich auch
richtig hart subventioniert.
Und das Essen ist gar nicht schlecht.
Das ist aber auch taktisch geschickt gemacht.
Also was ich gehört habe ist.
Warum das mit unserer Kantine so gut funktioniert.
Ich hoffe ich kriege das jetzt noch richtig zusammen.
Bei unserer Kantine.
Ist es so.
Die werden nicht bezahlt.
Nach.
Also die haben kein festes.
Ich kriege es nicht mehr zusammen.
Also die haben kein festes Budget.
So dass sie quasi.
Einfach nur sagen.
Ey.
Möglichst billiges Essen machen.
Die bekommen.
Irgendwie das Geld.
Ich habe es vergessen wie es ist.
Ich glaube die bekommen.
Die bekommen ihre.
Ihr Budget in der Kantine.
Nach.
Essens.
Also wie viel essen die.
Wie viele Leute dort reingehen.
Im Endeffekt.
Was im Endeffekt halt ein super Anreiz ist.
Gescheites Essen zu machen.
Weil du kriegst kein festes Budget.
Und musst es möglichst billig machen.
So dass du noch viel Kohle übrig hast.
Ne.
Du kriegst quasi.
Je mehr Leute da hingehen.
Und mit dem Essen zufrieden sind.
Umso mehr Kohle kriegst du auch.
Das finde ich haben sie taktisch.
Sehr feinfertig gelöst.
Weil ich habe schon genug Kantinen erlebt.
Wo es halt einfach eklig war.
Weil einfach nur billig rausgehauen wurde.
Also das ekligste.
Was ich mal in der Frankfurter Kantine hatte.
Das war hier.
Leute.
Mal ne blöde Frage.
Hatte Google nicht hier oben mal ein Button.
Wo Maps drauf stand.
Und man da drauf klicken konnte.
Der ist weg.
Aber warum ist der weg.
Das ist doch total dumm das der weg ist.
Aber warum ist.
Das ist ja richtig hängengeblieben.
Ich wohne wieder in Main heute.
Ok.
Google meint bestimmt wieder.
Ich wohne hier irgendwo.
Frankfurt.
Englisch.
Theater.
So.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Aber da war die Kantine irgendwo.
Die gibt es aber glaube ich gar nicht mehr.
Hier war früher die Commerzbank Kantine.
Irgendwo.
Kaiserstraße.
Hier.
Hier war.
Oh das war nicht schlecht.
Die haben nice Baguettes gemacht.
Da war eine Kantine drinnen früher.
Die Commerzbank Kantine.
Und das war seriously.
Galileo hieß das Ding.
Oder?
Frankfurt Galileo Kantine.
Die beste Kantine der Welt.
Achso.
Galileo.
Ok.
Ich dachte das hieß Galileo.
Bilder?
Ach deswegen weil das da in der Nähe ist.
Ok.
Zumindest.
Die Kantine.
Also hier in den oberen zwei Stöcken war das.
Nicht hier in dem Hochhaus.
Hier irgendwie in den ersten zwei Stöcken.
Oder so.
Ich weiß nicht wo genau.
Zumindest hier.
Das war die ekligste Kantine überhaupt.
Ich habe da mal Hähnchenbrust gefuttert.
Und dann habe ich die Hähnchenbrust umgedreht.
Und die eine Seite war komplett voll.
Mit Fusseln.
Aber jetzt nicht irgendwie Fusseln vom Hähnchen.
Sondern Fusseln.
Ja mit solchen Fusseln.
Mit so Schwammfusseln.
War das voll.
Richtig echt.
Das sah genau so aus.
Wie unten von so einem Schwamm.
Und da war die eine Seite von der Hähnchenbrust komplett voll mit.
Das war so eklig.
Diese Kantine war so rotz.
Boah.
Seitdem.
Bin ich da auch nur noch ein paar mal hingegangen.
Aber die gibt es mittlerweile.
Ne ne kein Schimmel.
Aber die gibt es mittlerweile auch nicht mehr.
Die war hier drinnen.
Ich vermute mal.
Die hat Corona nicht überlegt.
Die Fahrradwerkstatt.
Was haben die denn da?
Das ist so klein.
Da passt doch gar kein Fahrrad richtig rein.
Schaltung einstellen kann ich selbst.
Also ich muss sagen.
Seitdem ich mein Fahrrad habe.
Sind meine Mechanicore Skills improved.
Das hier ist so ein ultra teures.
Japanisches Restaurant.
Da steht so ein Typ vor dir.
Der macht dann das Essen.
Ort des ehemaligen Frankfurter Taunus Bahnhof.
Aha.
Naja gut.
Ist eigentlich totaler Schwachsinn.
Weil ich zeige euch jetzt was was es gar nicht mehr gibt.
Und zumindest das war das.
Das war das.
Die ekligste Kantine die ich kenne.
Hier bin ich jahrelang morgens raus gekommen.
Aus der U-Bahn.
Hier.
Gibt es hier Bilder von eigentlich?
Ja.
Hier bin ich jahrelang aus der U-Bahn raus gekommen.
Bin dann hier runter gelaufen.
Richtung Hausbahnhof.
Bis ich irgendwann auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen bin.
Lass doch vom Südbahnhof laufen.
Das habe ich ja schon seit ein paar Jahren gemacht.
Da bin ich vom Südbahnhof dann immer hier hoch gelaufen.
Zur Arbeit.
Und jetzt.
Mach ich das ganz anders.
Ne ist gar nicht so weit.
25 Minuten.
25-30 Minuten.
30 wenn du nicht so schnell bist.
Das ist aber ganz gut.
Dann hast du dich morgens schon ein bisschen bewegt.
Ich arbeite jetzt ein bisschen ja woanders.
Als noch zu der Zeit.
So ein Kilometer Luftlinie weiter weg.
Darfst du eigentlich jetzt liegen wo du damals gearbeitet hast?
Dürfte ich. Will ich aber nicht.
Also ich sag mal so.
Hat mir ja damals auch keiner verboten.
In dem Sinn.
Ja deswegen darfst du ja nicht schnell.
Du sollst ja nicht rennen. Du läufst halt.
Das hält man schon aus.
Normales Tempo.
Hochlaufen vom Südbahnhof.
Passt schon.
Jetgear.
Habe ich irgendwas spannendes diese Woche verpasst?
War irgendwas?
Bin gerade ein bisschen planlos.
War irgendwas spannendes?
Waren irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken die ich verpasst habe?
Oder war irgendwelche.
Irgendwelches Drama.
Das ich verpasst habe.
Vielleicht.
Heise hatte mal einen coolen Wochenrückblick.
Aber den gibt es irgendwie nicht mehr.
Informatiklehrer werden.
Ich weiß nicht wann ein Quereinstieg möglich ist.
Es ist mir voll und ganz egal wann ein Quereinstieg möglich ist.
Ich würde im Leben kein Lehrer werden.
Selbst wenn es möglich wäre.
Und selbst wenn die mir ultra viel Kohle bezahlen.
Sie müssten mir wirklich enorm viel Geld bezahlen.
Dass ich freiwillig Lehrer werden würde.
Und mich mit den ganzen Kackspasten da auseinandersetzen muss.
Ich weiß das ich war selbst einer früher.
Hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Alter.
Mir gehen Kinder schon auf den Sack.
Aber wenn mir.
Das geht ja noch irgendwie.
Aber Jugendliche die gehen mir sowas von auf den Sack.
Die gehen mir sowas von auf den Sack.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Im Leben nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht was mit dem Sibaro los ist.
Unserem Ober-Cute-Mod.
Der schon lange nicht mehr da war.
Dass der freiwillig Lehrer wird.
Ich kann das nicht verstehen.
Grundsätzlich Finger weg vom Fax.
Nice.
Auf die ganzen Gangster-Jugendlichen.
Auf gar keine.
Aber auf die besonders nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich.
Es ist alles Kacke.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle.
Grundschule da hast du ultra nervige Kinder am Start.
Nächste Stufe.
Hast du ultra nervige Kinder am Start.
Und ultra nervige so.
Halbstarke am Start.
Ja ich auch.
Ich auch.
Ich glaub viele denken das.
Von ihrem ehemaligen Ich.
Also ich wäre mir definitiv.
Mega auf den Sack gegangen.
Das kommt ja noch dazu.
Du musst dich mit den Eltern.
Auch auseinandersetzen.
Kunden können auch ziemlich nervig sein.
Da gebe ich dir Recht.
Deswegen vermeide ich.
Jeden Kundenkontakt.
Und hab damit glücklicherweise auch nichts zu tun.
Jetzt kommt natürlich irgendein Manager-Dude.
Im Zweifelsfall um die Ecke.
Und sagt. Ja aber intern sind die anderen.
Ja auch unsere Kundin.
Da denke ich mir immer. Ja ok. Erzählt was ihr wollt.
Das ist was anderes.
Es ist ein Unterschied.
Ob du irgendwohin mitgehst.
Als Techniker mit irgendwelchen Sales Leuten.
Und ihr müsst dann euer neues Monitoring System.
Irgendwelchen Leuten aufschwätzen.
Oder ob dein Kunde.
Intern jemand ist der sagt.
Ey guck mal hier unsere Festplatte ist voll gelaufen.
Kannst du mal gucken.
Das sind schon ein paar unterschiedliche.
Herangehensweisen.
Ja.
Und glücklicherweise.
80% Projekt.
Cloud Infrastruktur.
Und Automatisierung.
Und muss mich mit den ganzen Leuten nicht auseinandersetzen.
Letztens jemand.
Ultra glücklich gemacht auf der Arbeit.
Hat einer angerufen und meinte.
Hier unser Service.
Kann keine PDF signieren.
Ich.
Null Ahnung von dem Service.
Absolut kein Plan.
Habe ich den Entwickler angeschrieben.
Beziehungsweise.
Ne ist sogar falsch.
Der Entwickler hat mich angeschrieben.
So rum.
Ob wir mal gucken können.
Haben wir geguckt.
Haben festgestellt.
Im Trust Store.
Trusten die noch nicht.
Der neuen CA.
Der die PDF signt.
Und dann haben wir das eingespielt.
Und dann ging es easy.
Und dann kam das Problem.
Die hätten das halt auch gerne in ihrer Live Umgebung.
Dass sie wieder PDF signieren können.
Nicht nur in der Test Umgebung.
Da haben wir einen Call gemacht.
Mit denen.
Und da haben die übelst.
Panik geschoben.
So nach dem Motto.
Was machen wir jetzt.
Müssen wir dann ein Change für erstellen.
Und muss das durch das Change Advisory Board durch.
Und dann dauert das doch wieder Wochen.
Und sonst was.
Was können wir denn da machen.
Da habe ich ihnen vorgeschlagen.
Was haltet ihr denn davon.
Ich habe die Zeit in dem Call.
Ihr macht mir jetzt gleich ein Incident Ticket auf.
Dann logge ich mich auf die Produktion ein.
Importe das Zertifikat in den Trust Store.
Und dann geht es wieder.
Das geht.
Zum ersten Mal.
Ich habe noch nie ein Incident Ticket erstellt.
Wie geht das denn.
Ich habe mich eingeloggt.
Dann habe ich die sogar gefragt.
Wollt ihr zugucken wie ich das Zertifikat einspiele.
Das waren halt zwei.
Die hatten überhaupt keinen Plan.
Das war die Projektleiterin.
Von diesem PDF Signierungs Ding.
Und irgendein.
Weiß ich nicht.
Irgendein Projektmanager.
Die zwei.
Wollt ihr vielleicht sogar zugucken.
Wie ich das Zertifikat einspiele.
Dann habe ich über Teams mein Terminal geshared.
An zwei Leute.
Die in ihrem Leben.
Noch nichts im Terminal gemacht haben.
Dann habe ich das Zertifikat.
Rüber kopiert.
Per SCP.
In einer Trust Store.
Und.
Habe das importiert.
Dann habe ich gesagt.
So.
Probiert mal aus.
Da denke ich jetzt noch Wochen dran.
Hat sie gemeint.
Naja.
Zumindest waren die total happy.
Und dann dachte ich mir so.
Okay.
Das ist ja schön.
Freut mich.
Freut einen ja auch immer.
Und am nächsten Tag meinte die nochmal.
Ja danke.
Dass das alles so schnell geklappt hat.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht.
Okay.
Jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen Stonks Werbung machen.
Dann habe ich ihr noch geschrieben.
So nach dem Motto.
Wenn du mal meinem Chef über den Weg läufst.
Erzähl ihm doch mal.
Wie zufrieden du mit unseren Sachen immer so bist.
Weil der freut sich immer.
Wenn alles gut läuft.
Ja mache ich hundertprozentig.
Aber schon wieder plus.
Ja.
Ich sage euch.
Ich habe euch das schon oft gesagt.
Man muss gescheite Sachen machen.
Aber genauso oft das Brei treten.
Ja.
Bonus.
Den habe ich schon.
Wobei.
Für 2023 habe ich den gesichert.
Leute.
Ich muss mal.
Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Also.
Mit meinem Chef habe ich.
Ein Bonus Multiplikator.
Von 1,32.
Ausgemacht.
Also.
Das hängt immer daran ab.
Wie gut alles funktioniert hat und so.
Okay 1,32.
Das wird jetzt noch multipliziert.
Das wird glaube ich noch multipliziert.
Mit.
Gehen wir mal von aus.
Es läuft eigentlich.
Mal 3.
Okay.
Alter.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das wäre ja ultra viel Kohle.
Auf einen Schlag nochmal.
Ne das läuft.
Das muss anders.
Das muss anders laufen.
Das muss anders berechnet werden.
Weil das wären ja fast.
Ne.
Das kann nicht sein.
Das ist zu viel.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Nein Multiplikator.
Also das funktioniert folgendermaßen bei uns.
Das funktioniert.
Zumindest dachte ich bis eben.
Dass das so funktioniert.
Also das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Wobei doch.
Das funktioniert bei uns folgendermaßen.
Es gibt ein.
Bonus.
Der steht bei dir im Vertrag drin.
Das ist bei mir 12.000 Euro.
Und.
Dieser Bonus.
Also dieser feste Bonus.
Der schwankt.
Je nachdem.
Wie gut und schlecht es lief.
Bei einem selbst.
Bei der Abteilung in der man ist.
Und.
Insgesamt wie es bei der Versicherung so läuft.
Das heißt das schwankt.
Von.
0,8.
Bis 1,8.
Ja Moment Leute das war es noch nicht.
Das stimmt jetzt 100%ig was ich euch erzähle.
Weil das wäre echt ein bisschen viel.
So das schwankt von 0,8 bis 1,8.
Jeweils von diesen 3 Punkten.
0,8 heißt.
Es ist nicht so gut gelaufen.
1,8 heißt es ist extrem gut gelaufen.
Also so super.
Das keiner geplant hätte.
Ich habe.
Meine persönliche Zielerreichung ist 1,32.
Also möglich ist.
0,8 bis 1,8.
1,8 gibt es nie.
1,7 gibt es nie. 1,6 gibt es nie.
1,5 gibt es eigentlich auch nie.
Ab 1,4 muss nämlich der Chef.
Persönlich zum Vorstand hoch.
Und das sich genehmigen lassen.
Deswegen sind die persönlichen Zielerreichungen.
Eigentlich immer.
Zwischen 1,3 und 1,4.
Weil keiner Bock hat zum Vorstand zu gehen.
Und zu sagen.
Der war so geil dieses Jahr.
Es ist mir auch wurscht.
So.
Ich habe 1,32.
Oh du hast recht.
Ich darf dir nicht mal 3 rechnen.
Du hast recht.
So geht das.
Ja das ist realistischer.
Nicht mal 3.
Du hast recht.
Blödsinn was ich da gerechnet habe.
Kompletter Blödsinn.
So muss man das.
Bugelkuch weiß wie es funktioniert.
So.
Das ist jetzt 1,32 wurde für mich festgelegt.
Ich weiß nicht.
Welcher Faktor festgelegt wurde.
Für die Abteilung.
Oder für die gesamte Versicherung.
Das wird glaube ich erst in einem Monat.
Oder so bekannt gegeben.
Aber gehen wir mal davon aus.
Das es mindestens 1,32 auch ist.
Also rechnen wir mal 1,32.
Mal 1,32 mal 1,3.
Dann ist das.
Der insgesamt so quasi.
Bonus Faktor.
Was dann heißen würde.
12.000 Euro mal.
Ok also gibt es einen Bonus.
Von 27.000 Euro.
27.600 Euro.
Aber nicht das ihr denkt.
Ich krieg den jetzt auf einmal überwiesen oder so.
Ich glaube das müsste hinkommen.
Ich krieg den nicht auf einmal überwiesen.
Und jetzt erzähl ich euch mal was.
Wo ihr euch wieder in den Kopf greifen werdet.
Ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung.
So.
Und ihr erinnert euch ja vielleicht noch so an.
Bankenkrise und sowas.
Ne ne in Aktien krieg ich das auch nicht.
Ihr erinnert euch ja vielleicht noch so an Bankenkrise.
Und sowas in der Richtung.
Vor ein paar Jahren.
Und da gab es doch nicht nur bei Banken.
Also generell in der Finanzbranche.
Bei Banken war es da ganz groß.
Aber bei Versicherungen auch.
In der Finanzbranche gab es ja damals in der Finanzkrise.
Einen riesen Aufschrei.
Das.
Zig Leute quasi ihr gesamtes.
Ersparte Vermögen.
Verloren haben und richtig Probleme hatten.
Und die Leute.
Super.
Viel Bonus kassiert haben trotzdem.
So nach dem Motto.
Alter.
Die Leute verlieren ihr Haus.
Ihr Wohnung.
Ihr Geld.
Aber irgendwelche Managementleute.
Und Bank und Finanzbranche Mitarbeiter.
Bekommen fetten Bonus.
Doch das war in der Finanzkrise so.
Deswegen.
Haben die jetzt gesagt.
Diesen Bonus gibt es nicht auf einmal.
Das macht zu schlechte Presse.
Diesen Bonus gibt es jetzt verteilt.
Über das ganze Jahr.
Aber.
Es gibt nicht mehr eine fette Bonuszahlung.
Damit sich keiner mehr.
In der Presse und sonst wo aufregen kann.
Das Leute die in der Finanzbranche arbeiten.
Zu große Bonus bekommen.
Auch wenn es schlecht läuft.
Ist eigentlich absolut Pfeiffer.
Ihr werdet jetzt nicht mehr erleben.
Das irgendwie der Banken.
Finanzbranche CEO.
Chef.
3 Millionen auf einmal überwiesen bekommt.
Sondern der bekommt die überwiesen.
Verteilt durch 12.
Dann fällt es nicht mehr so auf.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Wenn man zwischenzeitlich kündigt.
Oder gekündigt wird.
Dann hat man glaube ich gelitten.
Dann kriegt man das nicht nachträglich.
Und deswegen machen sie das jetzt so.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das so richtig funktioniert.
Deswegen machen sie das jetzt so.
Also diesen Bonus hier.
Den ich jetzt ausgerechnet habe.
Der wird quasi.
Aufgeteilt.
Auf 14 Monatsgehälter.
Allerdings wissen die ja noch nicht.
Im Jahr davor.
Welchen Bonus es.
Genau geben wird.
Deswegen rechnen die 0,8.
Mal 0,8.
Mal 0,8 glaube ich zumindest.
Genau.
Das gibt es dann schon über das Jahr verteilt.
Und den Rest.
Der dann sich dazu ergibt.
Den gibt es nochmal oben drauf.
Also kriege ich wahrscheinlich ungefähr 21.000 Euro.
Bonusüberweisung noch.
Irgendwann.
Ich glaube ich checke es nicht.
Ich checke es selbst nicht.
Keine Ahnung wie es.
Ich glaube das stimmt nicht was ich euch erzählt habe.
Also die Berechnung ist richtig.
So wie Bugelkuch das gesagt hat.
Aber.
Ich habe keine Ahnung wie es genau funktioniert.
Ich werde es sehen.
Gibt es Weihnachtsgeld.
Ja gibt es.
Es gibt 14 Monatsgehälter.
Also es gibt einmal.
Irgendwann jetzt so Geld.
Es gibt Ende des Jahres gibt es nochmal.
Ja es gibt 14 Monatsgeld.
Also quasi.
Du kriegst quasi im November oder so.
Kriegst du dann doppelt.
Irgendwie so.
Es ist nicht so dass ich es euch nicht sagen will.
Und super Geheimnis drum herum mache.
Aber ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Wie sich jetzt konkret berechnet.
Zumindest haben sie es so gemacht.
Dass das nicht so.
Nicht so.
Ich meine beim einfachen IT Typ wie mir.
Juckt es nicht.
Da sind die Bonuszahlen noch alles im Rahmen.
Aber wenn man sich irgendwelche.
Trading Leute da.
Oder so anguckt.
Die kriegen wahrscheinlich viel fetteren Bonus.
Und die verteilen das auch.
So dass es eben keine negative Presse mehr so geben kann.
Wie bei der Finanzkrise.
Ja würde ich auch machen.
Bei euch ist es doch ähnlich.
Chainlaw.
Beziehungsweise bei euch ist es wahrscheinlich genauso.
Also ich weiß das es bei euch ähnlich ist.
Ich weiß nicht ob es genau so ist.
Aber verteilt ist steuertechnisch besser.
Als alles auf einmal.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ne wahrscheinlich nicht.
Irgendwie so.
Ich bin mir selbst nicht ganz sicher.
Wie das berechnet wird.
Du hast nicht reingeguckt.
Einfach unterschreiben.
Wie gesagt.
Ich war bei einer Bank.
Ich bin nicht mehr bei einer Bank.
Ich bin jetzt bei einer Versicherung.
Also du musst so allgemein in die Finanzbranche wechseln.
Okay.
Das können wir uns dann angucken.
Was verdient ein Güterzug Lokführer?
Hab ich das nicht schon aufgemacht?
Das verdient ein Lokführer im Güterverkehr.
Wenn er nicht gerade streikt.
Vielleicht verdient er auch so viel weil er gestreikt hat.
Muss man als Entwickler Kobol maintainen?
Das kommt drauf an ob du Kobol Entwickler bist oder nicht.
Bist du Kobol Entwickler aber das im Mainframe umfällt.
Dann muss man wahrscheinlich Kobol maintainen.
Dann werden 99% der Entwickler auf dieser Welt kein Kobol maintainen müssen.
Wie sind wir jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen.
Auf diesen Bonus Kram.
Dustin danke für den Sub.
Ach so.
Weil ich erzählt hab,
das es wichtig ist ein bisschen Wärmung für sich selbst.
und seine Arbeit zu machen.
Im Job.
dran, und dann, weil jemand gesagt hat Bonus gesichert.
Dann ist mir eingefallen.
Dann habe ich gedacht, ich erzähl euch mal wie das mit Bonuszahlungen so ist.
Der Markt regelt das Chainized.
Weißt du doch.
Das Dumme ist, die FDP ist so am abkacken, ne?
Ich kann wahrscheinlich, also können kann ich schon.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich wieder die FDP wähle.
Außerdem haben die es ziemlich verkackt irgendwie.
Ich finde nicht, dass die einen guten Job machen.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt noch planloser, was ich wählen soll.
Aber glücklicherweise ist die nächste Bundestagswahl doch erst 2026, oder?
Oder 2025?
Wann nächste Bundestagswahl?
Bundestagswahl.
Not now.
2025.
Echt, wird das immer in ungeraden Jahren gewählt?
Aha.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Es wird auf jeden Fall, also bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl,
wird auf jeden Fall die AfD extrem viel Plus machen,
wenn das so ungefähr Bestand haben wird, was jetzt reinkommt.
Und die Linken fliegen wahrscheinlich,
sind die nicht schon rausgeflogen?
Das letzte Mal, die FDP fliegt wahrscheinlich auch raus.
Da bin ich echt mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Und wo ich auch gespannt bin, was rauskommt, ist bei den Amis.
Ja, ich glaube, bei denen ist das ja schon nächstes Jahr, gell?
Oder dieses Jahr sogar?
USA-Präsident-Wahl.
Ja, das ist sogar dieses Jahr schon.
2000, das ist dieses Jahr.
5. November.
Ja, mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Du solltest einen Reverse-Wahl-O-Mat machen,
der die Entscheidung der letzten...
Ha.
Gibt es so was?
Einen Reverse-Wahl-O-Mat?
Wo du gucken kannst, was wurde von dem?
Oder wie zufrieden bist du mit dem, was die gemacht haben?
Das wäre eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht,
wenn einer so eine Seite erstellen würde.
Naja.
Ja, wie ist denn der aktuelle Trend?
CDU, CSU?
Da freuen sich die Bayern?
Was sonst, ne?
CDU, AfD, SPD?
Also, eins muss man sagen, die Grünen machen einen echt guten Job in der Form,
dass die eigenen Leute sie geil finden und die anderen halt kacke.
Deswegen ist halt...
Das sind die einzigen, die aus der ganzen Sache plus, minus, null rauskommen.
SPD geht runter, FDP...
Ach so, Moment, das ist Umfrage zur letzten.
Wir müssen mal gucken.
Vergleich...
Vergleich zur letzten Wahl.
Ja, guck mal.
Ähm, die SPD ist übelst runter.
Guck mal, die...
Guck mal, die SPD mega viel weg.
FDP ultra...
Auch mega viel weg.
Die Grünen sind mehr oder weniger das Gleiche.
Stimmt, sie haben es jetzt endlich geschafft mit Cannabis-Konsum, ne?
Da warte ich ja schon seit Anfang an drauf, ja.
Endlich, Vape Nation, let's go.
Leute, ich habe noch nicht einmal in meinem Leben was in der Richtung geraucht.
Also, werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht anfangen jetzt mit, wenn es legal ist.
Also...
Okay, das war nicht ganz ehrlich.
Ich habe mir nie was gekauft.
Sagen wir es mal so.
So, ich finde das nice.
Ich finde das nice.
Das ist vor allem was, was sie von Anfang an angekündigt haben.
Ja, kann schon sein.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie viel ich euch erzählt habe.
Ich meine, ich mache seit 14 Jahren YouTube.
Da habe ich bestimmt die ein oder anderen Sachen schon verraten.
Der Markt regelt das.
So, gucken wir mal ein paar YouTube-Videos.
Was haben wir denn Schönes?
Ich wollte ja den Logführer gucken.
Wo ist er denn?
Mach mal Update.
Hier unten?
Ja, nee.
Wenn ich jetzt Update mache, dann will er neu starten.
Beste Idee.
Wie viele Tabs?
Ich habe hier Tabs.
Ich habe hier nicht viele Tabs.
Und ich habe glücklicherweise hier keine Tabs gerade.
Warum?
Warum habe ich...
Otto und Media Markt am Start bei meinem Firefox.
Was ist das denn?
Deutsche Ottolan.
Was geht denn hier ab?
Warum ist...
Sponsored.
Geh mal weg.
Was ist das denn?
Dismiss.
Ja.
Ich glaube, es geht los.
Ja, Sponsored.
Ich habe es auch gesehen.
Auf der anderen Seite...
Ich kann das doch eigentlich...
Eigentlich kann ich es drinnen lassen.
Eigentlich kann ich es drinnen lassen, weil ich hoffe,
dass es Firefox noch lange geben wird.
Und ich hoffe, dass Firefox weiterentwickelt wird.
Und ich hoffe, dass Firefox,
selbst wenn Chrome immer beschissener wird,
weiterhin taugt.
Wenn die mit ihrer Manifest-Geschichte dann wieder um die Ecke kommen und sowas.
90% aller dieser ganzen Browser sind Chrome.
Edge ist auch Chrome.
Max FPS League aus der Suppe ist das, oder?
Ach so, ja.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Da war ich noch eine ganze Ecke dicker, als ich das Video aufgenommen habe.
Hier, guckt mal.
Da sieht man die Silhouette.
Wobei das echt auch unglücklich ist mit dem Schatten hier.
Da war ich aber noch eine ganze Ecke dicker.
Hier sieht man auch den Bauch noch.
Am Ende leake ich mich ja auch noch mal irgendwo.
Guck mal hier.
Leaked.
So viel geleakt.
Ne, zu dünn bin ich nicht.
Chainlaw, warum bist du eigentlich VIP?
Wie hast du das geschafft?
Da kann ich mich ja überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Aus was hat mich geritten, dass der Chainlaw VIP ist?
Ach, du hast die Emotes gemacht.
Ja, okay.
Dann ist...
Das ist gerechtfertigt.
Dann ist okay.
Ja, es hat alles was mit Emotes zu tun.
Neues Arch-Update, by the way.
Habe ich doch heute Morgen schon gemacht.
Oder noch heute Morgen.
Noch mal.
Leaked.
Was ist App-Stream?
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Aber es muss geupdatet werden.
Oh, Arch-Dealung ist geupdatet.
So, also, gucken wir uns das doch mal an.
Gutes Gehalt bei Privatarbeit.
Das verdient ein Lokführer im Güterverkehr.
Ach, okay, der streikt auch nicht.
Weil er bei einer privaten Bahn ist.
Zeig mal her.
Jeder kleinste Fehler kann sehr schlimm werden.
Gibt ja auch so Statistiken, dass wie viele Leute quasi in einer Karriere
eines Lokführers auf die Gleise springen und sowas.
Also, leider schon aus dem Grund würde ich das nicht machen.
Sind bei der GDLA, die streiken auch.
So was nennt man Sport am Morgen.
Ich verdiene ja als Lokführer sehr gut.
Sehe ich gut aus?
Moin, ich bin der Yusuf.
Bin 37 Jahre alt.
Bin gelernter Lokführer.
Und wir fahren heute von Mainz-Bischofsheim nach Landshut.
Und wünsche euch dabei viel Spaß.
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk
Ich wünsche euch dabei viel Spaß.
Grüße dich.
Hast es geschafft?
Ja, sicher, endlich.
Schlaf gut, ciao.
Da musst du halt immer zu irgendwelchen komplett un...
Mein Opa hätte gesagt, zu unchristlichen Zeiten früh aufstehen.
Obgesagt ist es nichts anderes als ein Personalwechsel.
Das heißt, die Lokführer wechseln sich ab.
Er geht runter, ich gehe drauf und fahre weiter.
Ich kontrolliere jetzt im Prinzip die Liste.
Bezüglich an meinen Fahrplan gucke ich, ob soweit alles am Zug in Ordnung ist.
Ob die Länge, Gewicht...
Ach so, warum ist CC überhaupt an?
... soweit einstimmt. Und das sieht gut aus.
Wir haben einen leeren Autozug.
Das sind die Leerwagen, die in den Werk fahren, damit die wieder beladen werden mit den Autos.
Und die werden dann morgen Abend von mir wieder zurückgefahren.
Ja, grüße dich, der Yusuf hier in 510.
Ob da auch Windows 3.11 läuft?
Ich fahre wieder abfahrbereit.
So.
Nur wenn es Züge von Siemens sind, ne? Mit Windows 3.11.
Also diese Anzeigen hier, wer weiß, vielleicht ist es Windows 3.11.
Du darfst nicht deine Konzentration nachlassen.
Jeder kleinste Fehler kann sehr schlimm werden.
Eine Entgleisung, zu schnell in die Weichen reinfahren.
Toi, toi, toi. Also ich hatte bis jetzt, außer dass ich einen Wildunfall hatte
oder dass jetzt ein Ast im Gleisbereich lag, jetzt nichts Radikales.
Es ist auch so, dass Leute gar keinen Rücksicht haben.
Und meinen, dass es eine Abkürzung ist.
Ja, eine Abkürzung, dass das Leben beendet.
Wenn ich am Fahren bin, bin ich komplett konzentriert.
Die Sache ist...
Abkürzung, dass das Leben beendet.
Es könnte auch JavaScript sein, Leute.
Bei SpaceX sehen die Dinger ähnlich aus und sind JavaScript.
Wenn ich am Fahren bin, bin ich komplett konzentriert.
Da denke ich auch nicht an Müdigkeit oder so.
Ich habe immer meinen Kaffee dabei oder meinen Tee.
Kommt drauf an, aber ich trinke jetzt. Ich fühle mich jetzt nicht...
Ob der auch alle paar Sekunden den Knopf drücken muss, dass er noch wach ist?
Nicht mit irgendwie, mit Energydrinks voll oder sowas.
Da muss ich ja öfter aufs Klo.
Ich habe 5600 Pferdestärken.
Toss, Toss, Musik, Toss.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist, aber es ist bestimmt Toss.
Toss, Toss.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, dass jemand, der nur Personenverkehr gefahren ist,
von heute auf morgen auf Güterverkehr umswitcht,
schon seine Probleme haben wird beim Bremsen oder beim Fahren.
Weil es ja gar nicht kennt, mit der Last zu fahren.
Es werde Licht. Pause.
Ich würde jetzt einfach mal ein Stück frische Luft schnappen.
Einfach die Beine ein bisschen vertreten, weil ich sitze ja die ganze Zeit.
Boah, welche Uhrzeiten, Alter.
Wir haben aktuell 5 Uhr und wir sind 160 Minuten immer noch vor Plan.
Ich trete die ganze Zeit auf die Sifa.
Es ist ein Zugbeeinflussungssystem, eine Sicherheit, der überwacht mich.
Dass im Prinzip die Lok weiß, dass ich noch da bin, mir es gut geht.
Also ich finde auf jeden Fall, dass ich gut verdiene.
Ah, der muss keinen Knopf drücken, der muss ein Pedal drücken.
Aber ich weiß auch, dass ich viel dafür mache.
Natürlich opfere ich auch viel dafür, weil ich ja auch ständig unterwegs bin.
Wir sind beim privaten Eisenbahnunternehmen.
Ich verdiene auf jeden Fall viel mehr als ein normaler Lokführer,
der jetzt bei der GDL bezüglich bei der Bahn arbeitet.
Wir sind jetzt gerade ungefähr 25 Minuten.
Wir sind 25 Kilometer vor Regensburg.
Uhrzeittechnisch sollten wir um 8.44 Uhr hier sein und wir haben gerade 6 Uhr.
Ja, kein Wunder, dass er nicht bei der Bahn arbeitet.
Wir sind zu früh, das kommt da nicht vor.
Hat der dir irgendwas gesagt, wann er mich annimmt?
Ja oder schon?
Lanzon verweigert uns.
Der muss erstmal seine Gleise freiräumen.
Es könnte sich eine Stunde bis zwei Stunden handeln.
Wir sind zu früh.
Kann er jetzt pennen, wenn er eine Stunde warten muss?
Wir werden jetzt irgendwo zur Seite genommen in Regensburg.
Bis jetzt bin ich noch nicht irgendwie im orangen oder roten Bereich,
wo ich jetzt Alarmglocken schlagen müsste, um zu sagen, ich komme über meine Zeit.
Ich würde jetzt einfach die Augen ausruhen, warten, bis das Telefon klingelt.
Augen ausruhen, das ist eine gute Umschreibung für Ich-Penne-Runde, oder?
Das sage ich ab jetzt auch.
Leute, ich gehe mal kurz die Augen ausruhen.
Bettke.
Däumchen drehen.
Nein, Toss, Toss.
Toss.
Alter, hör auf.
Alter, die spielen im Hintergrund die ganze Zeit Toss-Musik.
Das geht nicht.
Ich musste jetzt drüber labern, sorry, Leute.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Der hat richtig nice das Augentraining gemacht jetzt.
Hier kommst du, Toss.
Ich wollte Pilot werden, als Kind.
Aber ich sage, jetzt bin ich Pilot auf den Schienen.
Jetzt werde ich rausgehen, die Lok vom Wagenpark trennen.
Ich habe jetzt die Lok vom Wagenpark getrennt,
die Luft rausgelassen, dass der eingebremst ist.
So was nennt man Sport am Morgen.
Ich bin hellwach jetzt.
Jetzt können wir wieder.
Ja, jetzt ist er hellwach, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Unsere Lok.
Und können jetzt die Lok umsetzen.
Ich nehme meine Watts normalerweise nicht bei Twitch raus.
Ja, weiß Bescheid, ich danke dir.
Ich meine, das war jetzt immer nur eine Sekunde,
dann habe ich ausgemacht, das sollte schon okay sein.
So, jetzt haben wir die Zustimmung,
dass wir jetzt umsetzen können mit unserer Lokomotive.
Da müssen wir immer achten, weil wir eine E-Lokomotive sind,
dass wir auch immer in den Gleis fahren,
wo wir unter Strom stehen.
Das klingt sinnvoll, ja.
Sonst steht man da und kommt nicht weiter.
Wird das ein teurer Spaß.
So, dann wären wir jetzt in unserem Gleisbereich drinne,
wo wir jetzt unsere Lok abstellen.
Wichtig ist auch, dass man sich vom Funk abmeldet.
Ich verdiene.
Ich verdiene aktuell 4.055 Euro brutto den Grundgehalt.
Wir haben bei uns in der Firma
einen monatlichen Pauschale für die Mehrarbeit.
Ist das da schon drinne?
Nee, das kommt oben drauf.
Da bewegen wir uns doch jetzt in ordentlichen Regionen.
Nacht, Wochenenden und Sonntage.
Das ist brutto auf 1.150 Euro.
Max wird Lokführer.
Das wird leider nicht funktionieren.
Mit vier Tage Woche.
Und würde ich auch im Leben nicht machen wollen.
Hä, warum bleiben dem so viel Geld übrig?
Was ist das?
Ah, Steuerklasse 3.
Der ist verheiratet oder sowas wahrscheinlich, ne?
Krass, wie viel mehr Geld einem da übrig bleibt, ey.
Was ich jetzt nicht checke,
wie kommt der auf so viel brutto?
Hier sind das, ach so.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Es ist Grundgehalt 4.055.
Schichtzuschlag.
Zuschläge über Stunden.
Ah, ja, ja, ja.
Okay, okay, okay.
Also 7.325.
Na, das ist doch ordentlich, ja.
Heißt, wie viel netto?
Alter, Steuerklasse 3, das hat schon was, hä?
Du heiratest jetzt auch für...
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich muss so viel Steuern bezahlen.
Warte mal.
Hä?
Wait a minute.
Warum sind das jetzt auf einmal so wenig?
Jahresbrutto?
Eben waren das doch noch so viele im Monat.
Allein schon mit 10 Monaten sind das 73k?
Ach so, das ist Februar, Dezember und jeden Monat.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, dann relativiert sich das wieder,
weil bei mir sind es ja 14 Monatsgelder.
Und dann...
Ohne Stelz und so drauf.
Aber...
Dann ist es jetzt gar nicht mehr so krass.
Ich habe jetzt Feierabend.
Ich gehe jetzt ins Hotel, frühstücke, ruhe mich aus, schlafe und heute Abend...
Das ist halt auch kacke, ne?
Dass du dann den ganzen Tag irgendwo unterwegs bist
und dann auch nicht heim kannst und so.
Um 23 Uhr fahre ich die Tour mit dem vollen Zug wieder zurück.
Wir haben das Haus für eine halbe Million mit allem Drum und Dran erworben.
Easy money.
Das sind 1.800 Euro, wie wir das Haus bezahlen.
Monatlich.
Jetzt erst mal die Augen ausruhen daheim.
Okay.
Die Nebenkosten waren am Anfang recht angenehm
und aktuell liegen wir weit über 500 Euro.
Ich bin der Alleinverdiener aktuell.
In Moment ist meine Frau...
Ah, deswegen Steuerklasse 3.
Willst du Kartoffeln?
Ja, ich habe soweit alles erfüllt,
was ich mir so als Traum, als Vorstellung, Lebensaufgabe hatte.
Ja.
Ich habe eine glückliche Familie.
Ich tue viel Opfern, wenn ich nicht da bin.
Aber wenn ich mir überlege, was dieser Beruf alles bringt,
auch im finanziellen Bereich, lohnt sich das auf jeden Fall.
Moment, jetzt ist Torsten.
Jetzt muss ich die mal wieder ausmachen.
Ja.
Oh, geht schon was.
Er wirkt etwas emotionslos.
Das mag vielleicht sein, weil er gerade von 1 Uhr nachts bis...
Wann haben wir gerade gesehen?
Er gefühlt 18 Uhr unterwegs war.
Da würde ich auch emotionslos wirken.
Ich glaube, da bist du auch ziemlich platt,
wenn du das eine Weile gemacht hast.
Also, ich vergleiche das mal...
Ups.
Ich vergleiche das mal mit den Leuten,
die bei uns Schicht gearbeitet haben,
also beim alten Laden,
also beim letzten Arbeitgeber.
Da hatten wir ja auch Leute im 24-7-Support, nenne ich es mal.
Die hatten auch Nachtschicht regelmäßig
und die waren auch immer so im Schicht.
Die haben das jahrelang schon gemacht
und haben sich da auch irgendwie drauf eingestellt.
Aber die waren trotzdem jedes Mal kaputt.
Witzige Sache.
Einmal war ich, weiß ich noch...
Einmal war ich mit meinem Kollegen,
gleicher Kollege, der jetzt auch bei mir im neuen Job auch dort arbeitet.
Der hatte Frühschicht, aber irgendwie die Tage davor Nachtschicht.
Und da gab es irgendwie so ein komisches Innovationsmeeting-Gedöns,
was die da manchmal gemacht haben.
Und da ging es darum...
Ich sage jetzt einfach, ich denke mir jetzt mal ein Thema aus,
aber es war so etwas in der Richtung wie
Verbesserungsideen für Service XY.
So.
Und der Eigentliche aus seinem Team,
der dort hingehen sollte, war nicht da.
Da habe ich den Tim gefragt.
Da habe ich gesagt, hier, Tim, wollen wir nicht zusammen hin?
Ich bin da auch eingeladen.
Da hat er gesagt, ja, ich komme mit.
Und da haben wir da gehockt in so einem Meetingraum,
Tür zu, Heizung an.
Und haben uns ein bisschen darüber Gedanken gemacht,
wie man Service XY verbessern könnte.
Und ich gucke so neben mir und gucke mir so den Tim an.
Ich sehe da...
Also, das waren so...
Wie nennt man das?
Wie heißen diese Stühle?
Stühle frei...
stehend oder so?
Wie heißen diese Dinger denn?
Es gibt so Stühle, die haben keine Lehne und die haben kein...
Die haben keine Beine.
Die haben nur so einen Pfosten in der Mitte.
Und darauf musst du balancieren.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Freischwingerstuhl?
Nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Stuhl mit nur einem Bein.
Äh...
Nein.
Was? Was? Swobber?
Ne, da kann ich nicht danach suchen.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ich suche hier nicht nach...
Ja, ein bisschen sowas in der Richtung.
D-Hocker?
Ja!
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Genau sowas hier.
Sowas hier in der Richtung war das.
Da musst du...
Genau, genau so ein Ding meine ich hier.
Sowas war das.
Wobei das da unten noch steht...
Ich kenne die, die so rund sind.
Das schwingt, das schwingt...
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Da musst du drauf balancieren.
Zumindest sowas hatten wir in diesem Meetingraum.
In diesem Innovationsraum.
Die hat natürlich auch super innovative Stühle.
Da gucke ich so neben mir.
Und äh, ich sehe...
Der Tim hockt auf dem...
Mit dem wollte ich auch schon mal ewig was aufnehmen.
Der hockt auf diesem Stuhl drauf, ja.
Und schwingt immer weiter nach links.
Also immer weiter nach links, immer weiter nach links.
Hält sich aber noch am Tisch fest.
Und der ist halt mitten in dem Meeting eingepennt.
Weil zwei Tage Nachtschicht...
Dann Frühschicht.
Da ist er in dem Meetingraum für zwei Stunden.
Mit Heizung an, Fenster zu und so.
Der ist halt da drauf eingepennt.
Und das ist dann erst so richtig aufgefallen.
Weil es geschnarcht hat von der Seite.
Also Nachtschicht macht fertig.
Ey, die Stühle sind echt nice.
Zum ab und zu mal drauf hocken.
Ja.
Zum ganzen Tag drauf sitzen ist das nix.
Das ist sowas, wenn du irgendeine Besprechung hast.
Du mal dich kurz absetzen willst.
Mal kurz hinsetzen willst.
Ein bisschen drauf rumhampeln willst.
Das ist ganz nice.
Aber für täglichen Bürostuhl ist das nix.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ey, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Super Charge Your Linux Terminal mit...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Also ich gucke die Videos gerne von ihm.
Aber Warp ist was, das werde ich im Leben nicht benutzen.
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, das ist ein Terminal für Mac und Linux.
Vielleicht auch für Windows, keine Ahnung.
Was nur funktioniert mit einem Login.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Ein Terminal mit Cloud-Funktion.
Ein Login erfordert.
Du brauchst ein Login für dein Terminal.
Das ist übrigens die Seite.
Sieht pepega aus.
Hier sowas ist besser.
Also ganz ehrlich.
Außerdem, wenn ich mir das hier angucke, sieht das so aus, als ist das irgendein JavaScript-Verschnitt an Terminal.
Was wieder 3 GB RAM braucht und laggy as fuck ist, wenn du mehrere Sachen ausgibst.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das kommt mir nicht in die Tüdel.
Da bin ich vielleicht zu Boomer für.
Aber das muss nicht sein.
Rust-based.
Ne, das ist nicht Rust-based.
Mein Terminal ist Rust-based.
Weil blazingly fast written in Rust.
Bestes, hier.
Rust, Rust-Terminal.
Warp ist Rust.
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Warp ist, ähm...
JavaScript.
Aber UI bestimmt JavaScript.
Ja, ja, sag ich doch.
Wir können mal checken, was es ist.
Sofern man das downloaden kann.
Download.
RPM, Debian.
Gibt es das nicht als TarGZ oder irgendwas?
TarGZ.
Arch Linux TarGZ.
Bestes, jawohl.
Dann machen wir das doch mal hier.
Ich will das nicht ausführen.
Ich will das nur entpacken.
ZST.
Wie entpackt man ein TarZST?
An Z...
Ne.
An...
Z...
Okay.
Jetzt können wir mal gucken,
aus was das besteht.
User.
Bin.
Warp-Terminal.
Ist das ein Skript?
Startet.
Opt.
Ne, das ist aus irgendeinem Game.
Keine Ahnung.
Meetopia.
Warp-Terminal.
Aus was besteht das Ganze?
Ja, irgendein Binary.
Tja, schön. Weiß man halt nicht.
Nicht Pfeilen, Alter.
Ja, irgendein Binary.
Schwer zu sagen, aus was das Ganze besteht.
Strings.
Äh, ja.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Das ist 100 pro irgendein Node.js-Ding, Alter.
Ja, guck mal hier.
Rust.
Es ist fucking Rust mit drinne auch, schau mal.
Okay.
Cargo. Das sieht sehr nach Rust aus.
Unwrap.
Da sind auch Cloud-Modules drinne.
Da ist auch JavaScript-Zeug drin.
Ja, es ist ne Elektron-App.
Ach, was auch immer.
Irgendeine Mischung aus...
Wenn man das jetzt noch richtig schreiben könnte.
Irgendeine Mischung aus JavaScript und Rust.
How Warp Works.
Es stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass es entirely built in Rust ist.
Wir haben doch eindeutig gesehen, dass es zum Teil auch ne Elektron-Anwendung ist.
Built in Rust and rendering directly on a GPU.
Dann ist bloß noch Rust mit drinne.
Damit nur Node mit drinne und Elektron mit drinne.
Just because. Keine Ahnung.
Okay, anscheinend ist es wirklich reines...
Ach, was auch immer.
Es fällt für mich eh komplett flach, weil Login.
Ich sehe es nicht ein, dass ich mich einloggen muss für nen Terminal.
Ach, da gibt's den Source-Code, oder was?
Nee.
Also, das erste, es ist nicht Open Source und es braucht nen Login.
Zwei Sachen, wo ich keinen Bock drauf hab für mein Terminal.
Westterm ist einfach nice.
Ich könnte mir also wirklich aktuell kein besseres Terminal vorstellen.
Ja, das hat keine AI-Funktion.
Ich wüsste jetzt aber auch nicht, wo ich wirklich täglich laufend AI-Funktionen bräuchte im Terminal.
Ja, du brauchst nen Login für das Terminal, dass es funktioniert.
Das ist halt super weird.
So, das können wir uns dann angucken.
Warum hab ich das zweimal auf?
Keck, wait.
Was ist das denn?
Das Ende von PayPal und Apple.
Warum?
Weil?
Weil digitale Euro.
Im Leben nichts.
Okay, ich hab mich da mit null beschäftigt.
Aber wenn die IT-Projekte dort genauso geil funktionieren wie unsere IT-Projekte in Deutschland,
dann hab ich da so meine Zweifel.
So bezahl ich ungefähr immer.
Handy aus, bezahlt.
Ja, so mach ich das auch.
Ja, ist halt Apple Pay oder auch Google Pay, hab ich ne Mastercard oder ne Visa hinterlegt.
Also bei Apple Pay hab ich beides hinterlegt.
Ich hab ne Kreditkarte hinterlegt und ich hab meine Sparkassenkarte hinterlegt,
weil manche Läden kommen nicht mit der Sparkassenkarte klar und manche Läden kommen nicht mit der Kreditkarte klar.
Es ist komisch, aber es ist gut beides drin zu haben.
Wenn ich privat irgendwie Geld verschicken will, dann nehm ich halt PayPal.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ihr das auch macht, halt ich für ziemlich hoch.
Das ist ja auch viel praktischer als Bargeld.
Allein, dass man nicht mehr mit Wechselgeld herumhantieren muss und auch keine bazillenverseuchten Pinpads mehr anfassen muss,
weil ja alles auf dem eigenen Smartphone passiert.
Aber natürlich hinterlässt man damit auch ne fette Datenspur.
Und an jeder Bezahlung von mir verdienen zum Beispiel Apple Mastercard, Visa, PayPal mit alles US-amerikanische Unternehmen.
Beides findet die europäische Zentralbank nicht so super und will deshalb eine neue Zahlungskurzigkeit einführen.
Den digitalen Euro.
Und der soll das Beste aus beiden Welten vereinen.
Okay, das Ding wird dann irgendwann eingeführt und nach 10 Jahren stellt man fest, oh, es benutzt keiner.
So ein bisschen wie ne Kryptowährung.
So ein bisschen wie diese tollen... Was ist eigentlich aus dieser neuen Gesundheitskarte geworden, wo auch so geile Sachen mit möglich sein sollen?
... wie Bitcoin funktionieren, nur dass der digitale Euro von der europäischen Zentralbank herausgegeben wird und dadurch genauso wertstabil wie der Euro.
D-E-Mail, ja, ist auch so'n Ding.
In diesem Video seht ihr, welche...
Ich kenn jemand, der hat bei D-E-Mail... Oder, warte mal, wie heißt das andere?
Es gab doch zwei Sachen. Es gab D-Mail und Posts. Wie hießen das andere?
D-Mail und Post. Irgendwas mit Post gab es noch.
E-Postbrief!
Ja, genau. Ja, das gab's auch noch.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wo mein ehemaliger Kollege gearbeitet hat, ob's D-Mail oder E-Post war.
Aber das war auch so'n Rohrkrepierer.
...Vorteile so'n digitaler Euro hätte, aber vor allem auch, welche Kritikpunkte und Risiken es gibt.
Und als Bonus kriegt ihr endlich ne Antwort drauf, warum man in manchen Läden nicht mit dem Handy, sondern nur mit der sogenannten EC-Karte bezahlen kann.
Bleibt dran!
Die Werkerin, liebe Internet-Server, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Also die Idee hinter dem digitalen Euro ist, dass er eine digitale Version des physischen Bargelds sein soll.
Das bedeutet, dass er sich vom Geld auf unseren Bankkonten unterscheidet.
Er ist also näher dran an den Geldscheinen, die wir im Portemonnaie haben, als am Geld, das wir auf unseren Bankkonten haben.
Und trotzdem soll er das können, was das Geld auf unserem Konto kann.
Warum ist das wichtig?
Bargeld wird durch das Bezahlen mit Karte oder Smartphone und Online-Shopping zunehmend von privaten Zahlungen erzeugt.
Große Tech-Konzerne verfügen über enorme Daten-Marktmacht.
Und das ist für die Europäische Zentralbank ein Dorn im Auge.
Ganz einfach, weil sie befürchtet, als staatliche Institution ihren Einfluss zu verlieren.
Eine der Hauptmotivationen für den digitalen Euro war damals Libra.
Also ein amerikanisch geführtes Konsortium, an dem auch die Facebook-Muttergesellschaft Meta beteiligt war.
Gibt's das noch? Libra-Coin?
Ach, Facebook-Diam heißt das jetzt, okay.
Wie sieht der Kurs aus? Gibt es nicht mehr, okay.
Könnte für europäische Verbraucher und Verbraucherinnen tatsächlich unschön enden.
Denn im Zweifelsfall entscheiden dann amerikanische Unternehmen darüber, was wir mit unserem europäischen Geld machen können.
Klar, oft sind diese Zukunftsszenarien extrem pessimistisch und ein bisschen Aluhut-mäßig, aber es gibt auch konkrete Beispiele.
Was? Warum? Ich mag Aluhut-Sachen.
Ich bin nicht für solche Probleme.
2010 waren über Visa und Mastercard zum Beispiel keine Spenden mehr an Wikileaks möglich.
Und auch PayPal hatte 2010 während einer Spendenaktion von Wikileaks deren Konto für einige Tage gesperrt.
Wikileaks war also vom Mainstream-Zahlungsverkehr weitestgehend abgeschottet.
Und auch dieses Open-Source-Hacking-Gadget FlipperZero, über das wir ja schon mal Videos gemacht haben,
da hat PayPal zeitweise Geld einfach eingefroren.
Und das wäre mit dem digitalen Euro sehr wahrscheinlich nicht passiert.
Wahrscheinlich, weil noch gar nicht final geklärt ist, wie der digitale Euro genau funktionieren soll.
Das Projekt befindet sich seit November 2023 in der sogenannten Vorbereitungsphase.
Okay, also, da müssen wir wahrscheinlich vor 2044 nicht mit rechnen.
Bei der Geschwindigkeit.
Ich will jetzt nicht wieder von Anfang, aber Leute, bei uns ist ein Fahrradweg geplant.
Es ist südlich und südlich des Mains, von Hanau nach Frankfurt.
Und das ist teilweise schon seit über 10 Jahren in Planung.
Und es ist bisher nicht darüber rausgekommen, dass eine Machbarkeitsstudie angefertigt wurde.
Also wir sind nicht nur langsam, wir sind noch nicht mal Schneckentempo.
Was ist denn da noch, was kommt nach Schneckentempo?
Ich weiß, ich sidetracke mich wieder.
Aber ich möchte gerade mal kurz schauen, vielleicht gibt es ja Neuigkeiten.
Fahrradschnellweg Frankfurt Hanau.
Ja, oh, es gibt News vom Dezember.
Nee, nicht wirklich, oder?
Ja, genau, hier der Fahrradweg.
Nordmeinisch, hier, oder?
Wie sieht es denn aus?
Dazu erarbeitet der Regionalverband gemeinsam mit der Stadt Frankfurt seit Herbst eine Alternativ...
Aha!
Ich meine, der ist nur, der ist nur seit 2016 in der Planung.
Das kann man schon in Südmeinisch, wie sieht es da aus?
Ja.
Ja, der ist nur seit 2012 in Planung, Mensch.
Also, seit 2012, also du kannst nicht erwarten, dass man in fucking 12 Jahren einen Fahrradweg bauen kann.
Die Chinesen hätten ihr komplettes Land mit dem Fahrradweg ausgestattet in 12 Jahren.
Gut, da werden wahrscheinlich im Fundament, hat ein Fahrradweg ein Fundament?
Weiß nicht, ja.
Da werden wahrscheinlich ein paar Bauarbeiter einbetoniert im Fundament.
Ich meine, immerhin hätten die in 12 Jahren wahrscheinlich einen Fahrradweg gebaut, ja.
Ah ja, guck mal, 2020 hat der Regionalverband als erstes...
Man muss mal sagen, 2012 wurde das angekündigt, 2020 wurden die ersten Schritte einer Machbarkeitsstudie in Auftrag gegeben.
Die wurde 2023 vorgestellt.
Und auf Basis der Schritte werden die beteiligten Partner, welche über die weitere Umsetzung der Radschnellverbindung entscheiden,
diese sollen bis Ende 2023 vorliegen.
Das ist einfach so ein Witz, Alter.
Das ist so ein Witz.
Die müssen sich nicht wundern, dass keiner mehr Vertrauen in diesen ganzen Bullshit hat.
Und im Zweifelsfall fangen die an zu bauen und dann stellt man fest, dass auf dem Weg irgendwie die seltene Froschart nistet.
Und dann wird das drei Kilometer drum herum gebaut.
Nee, nee, ich habe mich genau über den gleichen Scheiß schon mal vor einem halben Jahr aufgeregt.
Aber es hat sich anscheinend auch nichts getan.
So. Also, Leute, wir reden hier von Menschen und Organisationen, Behörden, Planungsleuten, die es in 12 Jahren für einen Fahrradweg,
und man würde jetzt davon ausgehen, dass eigentlich ein Fahrradweg durchaus simpler umzusetzen ist,
als eine digitale Währung auf EU-Ebene.
Die haben 12 Jahre gebraucht, um eine Machbarkeitsstudie, und die sind, also, die haben 12 Jahre gebraucht und sind bisher über eine Machbarkeitsstudie nicht rausgekommen.
Also vor 2044 oder so müssen wir da wahrscheinlich nicht mit rechnen hier.
Die EZB und die EU-Kommission arbeiten also gerade die genauen Details aus.
In etwa soll das aber so funktionieren.
Stellt euch vor, ihr geht jetzt zu einem Geldautomaten und hebt 100 Euro ab.
Dann habt ihr 100 Euro weniger auf dem Konto, aber 100 Euro Bargeld im Portemonnaie.
Für einen digitalen Euro würde wahrscheinlich genau dasselbe gelten.
Nur, dass ihr das Geld vom Bankkonto nicht als Bargeld abhebt.
Ja, Indien fliegt zum Mond in der Zeit. From scratch.
Sondern es in digitale Euro umwandelt.
Dafür bräuchtet ihr dann beispielsweise ein digitales Portemonnaie, also eine Wallet-App zum Beispiel.
Auf eurem Smartphone, mit der ihr eure digitalen Euros verwaltet.
Chat, ich hab mal eine Frage von euch, äh, an euch. Ups.
Guck mal hier, so bezahlen privaten Zahlungsanbieter...
Ja, jetzt hab ich mich...
Bargeld wird durch das Bezahlen mit Karte oder Smartphone und Online-Shopping zunehmend von privaten Zahlungsanbietern verdrängt.
Ich weiß nicht, wo wir gewesen sind. Ich hab mal eine Frage an euch.
Wenn ich mir eine Wallet anlegen will...
Krypto... Krypto-Stells.
Wie und wo macht man das am besten?
Da braucht man ja eigentlich gar kein Online-Service für. Das ist ja gerade der Sinn davon.
Aber wenn man da kein Online-Service für braucht, heißt ja auch, das Wallet...
...ist Blockchain-spezifisch, oder?
Also ich mein, es gibt kein allgemeingültiges Wallet.
Also wenn ich beispielsweise Polygon machen will...
...dann brauch ich was anderes, wie für Bitcoin.
Ja.
Gibt es da irgendeine coole...
...einfach Hardware-Wallet?
Ja.
Leute, Sekunde. Ich muss mal ganz kurz...
Moment. Ich find, ich find, ich find hier...
Ich muss mal ganz kurz...
Aff, klo.
Boah, mein Bein, alter.
Boah, ich hab jetzt die ganze Zeit gesessen.
Ich war ja noch rennen hier kurz vorm Stream.
Boah, ich merk's mal, voll in der Wade heut.
Alter. Boah.
Es...
Es lief heut auch zu gut eigentlich.
Zu easy von der Zeit her.
Als dass ich's jetzt nicht merken könnte für den Bein, ey.
Okay.
Ich bin gleich wieder da. Ich geh mal kurz pinkeln.
Ich bin wieder am Start.
So.
Dann gucken wir uns das noch mal weiter an.
Große Tech-Konzerne verfügen über enorme Datenmarktmacht.
Und das ist für die Europäische Zentralbank ein Dorn im Auge.
Ganz einfach, weil sie befürchtet, als staatliche Institution ihren Einfluss zu verlieren.
Alles haben wir schon geguckt. Egal.
Eine der Hauptmotivationen für den digitalen Euro war damals Libra.
Also ein amerikanisch geführtes Konsortium, an dem auch die Facebook-Muttergesellschaft Meta beteiligt war.
Und ja, das könnte für europäische Verbraucher und Verbraucherinnen tatsächlich unschön enden.
Warum hat er denn einen Super-Nintendo-Controller in der Hand? Was ich übrigens nice finde.
Für mich immer noch mein Lieblingscontroller.
Und das ist das Problem.
Weil, entscheiden dann amerikanische Unternehmen darüber, was wir mit unserem europäischen Geld machen können.
Klar, oft sind diese Zukunfts-
Benutzt er den irgendwie zum Schalten von der Kamera oder so? Zum Aufzeichnungs- irgendwie- Steuern?
Extrem pessimistisch und ein bisschen Aluhut-mäßig.
Aber es gibt auch konkrete Beispiele für solche Probleme.
2010 waren über Visa und Mac- Ja, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Mainstream-Zahlungsverkehr weitestgehend abgeschottet.
Und auch dieses Open-Source-Hacking-Gadget Flipper Zero, über das wir ja schon mal Videos gemacht haben.
Das ist aber so sehr wahrscheinlich nicht passiert.
Ich sage wahrscheinlich, weil noch gar nicht final geklärt ist, wie der digitale Euro genau funktionieren soll.
Das Projekt befindet sich seit November 2023 in der sogenannten Vorbereitungsphase.
Die EZ-
Ja, das ist das, wo ich gerade gesagt habe. Da können wir vor 2044 wahrscheinlich nicht mit rechnen, so schnell wie die sind.
Die EU-Kommission arbeiten also gerade die genauen Details aus.
In etwa soll das aber so funktionieren.
Stellt euch vor, ihr geht jetzt zu einem Geldautomaten und hebt 100 Euro ab.
Dann habt ihr 100 Euro weniger auf dem Konto, aber 100 Euro Bargeld im Portemonnaie.
Für einen digitalen Euro würde wahrscheinlich genau dasselbe gelten.
Nur, dass ihr das Geld vom Bankkonto nicht als Bargeld abhebt, sondern es in digitale Euro umwandelt.
Dafür bräuchtet ihr dann beispielsweise ein digitales Portemonnaie, also eine Wallet-App zum Beispiel auf eurem Smartphone,
mit der ihr eure digitalen Euros verwaltet, zum Zahlen benutzt oder sie an Freunde schickt.
Unklar ist zum Beispiel noch, ob es eine Obergrenze für digitale Euro gibt.
Und vor allem, wie hoch diese sein könnte.
Also ehrlich Leute, ich sag euch mal, was passieren wird.
Die führen das bestimmt irgendwann ein, aber die Benutzung ist komplizierter als Apple Pay.
Und deswegen verwendet es keiner.
Apple Pay hat sich durchgesetzt, weil es halt super easy ist und integriert im Smartphone.
Du drückst zweimal auf die Back-Taste, Sperrentaste, hältst ans Lesegerät ran, fertig.
Das ist halt easy.
Es gab ja vorher schon die ein oder anderen Versuche, ja.
Es gibt auch viele Leute, die haben mit Karte bezahlt und PIN eintippen.
Oder da gab es mal sowas wie Lidl Pay. Hat mal jemand von euch Lidl Pay benutzt?
Ich hab das mal testweise ausprobiert.
Für Lidl Pay musstest du eine App runterladen von Lidl, dort deine Bankverbindung hinterlegen
und dann musstest du dein Handy in so eine Kamera halten an der Kasse vom Lidl.
Die haben so einen QR-Code dann daraus gescannt.
War total umständlich.
Und Apple Pay und auf Android das Gegenstück.
Ja, ja, Lidl Pay gab es auch mal. Habe ich ausprobiert. Das war halt voll für den Arsch.
Und das ist halt easy.
Und wenn ich eins mittlerweile gelernt habe, den Leuten ist Datenschutz egal, solange es easy ist.
Das siehst du an ganz vielen Ecken und Enden.
Sobald man etwas einfach haben kann, scheißen die Leute auf alles und machen das einfache.
Und das Problem ist nicht neu, weil die Diskussion um, sagen wir mal, Security versus Easy Usables, also ease of use und so,
das ist ja so alt, wie es das Thema gibt.
Bequemlichkeit versus Sicherheit. Das war schon immer. Das ist nichts Neues.
Was ich dann immer witzig finde ist,
wenn die Leute sich das irgendwie so schön reden.
So nach dem Motto, ja, die können doch meine Daten haben. Ich habe nichts zu verbergen.
Und was sollen die schon damit machen und sowas.
Ist ja schön und gut.
Aber ehrlicher wäre es zu sagen,
ja, ich weiß, dass meine Daten wo landen, wo ich dann nicht weiß, was damit passiert.
Aber es ist mir egal. Ich nehme das in Kauf.
Mir ist wichtiger, dass es bequem ist.
So, gucken wir weiter.
Etwa 3000 Euro im Gespräch.
Aber auch eine extra Karte für den digitalen Euro wäre denkbar.
Inwiefern man beim digitalen Euro die Anonymität von Bargeld beibehalten wird, ist zurzeit auch noch unklar.
Etwas klarer ist aber schon, wie die Sicherheit beim digitalen Euro geleistet werden soll.
Die Europäische Zentralbank hat sich dazu nämlich schon viele Gedanken gemacht und favorisiert derzeit sogenannte Token.
Ja, was bedeutet das?
Also, die Europäische Zentralbank hat sich dazu entschieden,
dass die Europäische Zentralbank einen digitalen Platzhalter erhält.
Das heißt, es gibt dann eine EU-Blockchain, oder wie?
Stellt euch das vor wie das digitale Abbild einer 10-Euro-Banknote.
Also quasi ein NFT.
So könnten Händler und Kunde über einen Zwischenhändler, einen sogenannten Intermediär, arbeiten,
der jeweils nur die Zahlung validiert, aber nicht verrät, wer die Zahlung ausgelöst hat.
Diese Idee würde eine Abkehr von klassischem Kontodenken bedeuten,
und nicht nur technische, sondern auch rechtliche Fragen aufwerfen.
Ich finde den Ansatz gar nicht mal so doof.
Die wichtigste Frage dabei, wer und was stellt sicher, dass kein digitales Falschgeld erzeugt wird?
Ja, und daran wird halt gerade noch gearbeitet.
Ja gut, das wie bei jeder anderen Kryptowährung?
Ah, wobei, ne, das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach.
Weil bei anderen Kryptowährungen gibt es ja da verschiedenste...
...Proof und Rechenaufwände, die geleistet werden müssen, wo man dann für Transaktionen oder für...
...Unterstützungen bei Transaktionen irgendwelche...
...Quasi kleine Ausschüttungen von der jeweiligen Währung bekommt.
Das kostet dann halt quasi Geld oder Strom oder wie auch immer.
Aber muss ja erstmal errechnet werden.
Der digitale Euro basiert ja schon auf bestehendem Euro.
Also keine Ahnung, wie man das gescheit macht.
Da fällt denen schon irgendwas ein.
Es gibt keine Blockchain, anscheinend nicht.
Blockchain würde ja auch bedeuten, du kannst öffentlich alle Transaktionen oder du kannst alle Transaktionen nachvollziehen.
Was wahrscheinlich so gar nicht gewollt ist.
Zumindest nicht von jedem Dude im Internet.
Das Modell könnte aber auf jeden Fall für mehr Privatsphäre...
Eigentlich wäre das doch cool, oder?
Wenn alle Transaktionen nur öffentlich wären?
...als jede andere digitale Zahlungsform sorgt.
Unter Gesichtspunkten der Privatsphäre wäre nur ein reines Bargeld-Szenario noch diskreter.
Ja, aber niemand glaubt wohl daran, dass wir einfach komplett wieder zu Bargeld zurückkehren.
Das wird nicht passieren.
Ja, und nach den Vorstellungen der EZB sollen Zahlungsdaten nur in dem Umfang gespeichert werden, den die Zahlungsabwicklung erfordert.
Ja, was genau ist aber jetzt der Unterschied zwischen dem digitalen Euro und anderen digitalen Zahlungsmöglichkeiten wie Paypal oder Online-Banking?
Neben dem Aspekt Einfluss von privaten Unternehmen und natürlich den Datenschutz auf einen klar kontrollierbaren europäischen Standard zu bringen, gibt es vor allem zwei Unterschiede.
Der eine sind die Gebühren, die bei der Benutzung fällig werden.
Da gibt es noch keine genauen Gebührenpläne, aber es gilt als ziemlich sicher, dass die Benutzung des digitalen Euro...
Monero, Monero-Bestel. Hat nicht Cristiano Ronaldo sogar Monero gemeint auf seiner Webseite?
...Euros für Händler viel günstiger wäre als etwas anderes.
Da gibt es etwa eine Zahlung über Mastercard oder Paypal.
Falls es euch interessiert, was das für Händler konkret kostet und warum manche nur EC-Karten, also richtig Giro-Cards, akzeptieren, das erkläre ich am Ende des Videos.
So, genau, der erste Unterschied zwischen digitalem Euro und, sagen wir mal, Visa-Karte liegen in den Gebühren.
Der zweite liegt in der Art des Geldes, Zentralbankgeld oder Giralgeld.
Für Privatleute gibt es Zentralbankgeld bislang nur als analoges Bargeld.
Also Papier und Münzen.
Wer allerdings über Banken und Paymentservices zahlt, nutzt Giralgeld.
Das ist Buchgeld der Banken, die davon mehr erzeugen, als sie selbst an Zentralbankgeld halten.
Das ist also zumindest in der Theorie unsicherer.
Der digitale Euro ist Zentralbankgeld in digitaler Form und somit so sicher wie Bargeld.
Für die meisten Menschen wird das in ihrem täglichen Leben jetzt aber keinen wirklichen Unterschied machen.
Wenig Bedeutung haben, ja.
Schon allein weil Banken in Deutschland verpflichtet sind,
Einlagen bis 100.000 Euro abzusichern.
Es gibt aber eine große Frage.
Werden Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher, Händler, Unternehmen und die Euro-Mitgliedsstaaten
selbst den digitalen Euro überhaupt akzeptieren?
Die EU-Kommission hat da schon mal einen Plan.
In ihrem Richtlinienentwurf vom Juni 2023 steht, dass der digitale Euro
neben Bargeld ein weiteres verpflichtendes Zahlungsmittel werden soll.
Das heißt, Unternehmen
Ja, bis 2044 oder so, oder?
Und offizielle Stellen müssen ihn grundsätzlich als Zahlungsmittel akzeptieren.
Sowohl online als auch im Laden um die Ecke.
Das Problem, das gilt auch für Bargeld.
Und da reicht es aktuell, einfach einen Aushang im Kassenbereich zu haben,
dass Bargeld nicht akzeptiert wird und nur Kartenzahlung möglich ist.
Das Gleiche könnte der Einzelhandel dann auch einfach mit dem digitalen Euro machen.
Da sind die niedrigeren Gebühren für Händler wahrscheinlich der größere Anreiz,
den digitalen Euro zu akzeptieren.
Es geht beim digitalen Euro,
aber nicht nur um das Bezahlen in Geschäften oder Onlineshops.
Damit könnten auch Zahlungen zwischen Maschinen einfacher werden.
Stellt euch vor, euer Auto bezahlt die Parkgebühr,
das Tanken oder die Maut quasi im Vorbeifahren.
Das wäre einfacher, weil die EZB plant,
Grundfunktionen des Zahlungsverkehrs kostenlos anzubieten.
Das bedeutet, dass Unternehmer und Geschäftsinhaber
bei Kleinstbeträgen, den sogenannten Micropayments,
keine Gebühren mehr zahlen müssen.
Damit würde eine große Hürde beim Bargeldlosen
im Bezahlen verschwinden.
Das heißt im Endeffekt auch,
du kannst dann beim Dönerladen tatsächlich damit bezahlen,
die das ja heute oftmals noch nicht haben.
Parkhaus, das einzelne Brötchen oder der einzelne Internetnachrichtenartikel
für wenige Cent könnten also ohne zusätzliche Kosten abgerechnet werden.
Aber auch zwischen Privatleuten wäre die Echtzeitbezahlfunktion praktisch,
beispielsweise auf Flohmärkten oder bei Kleineinzeigen,
wo heute noch viel mit Bargeld herumhantiert wird.
Aber nicht alles, was glänzt, ist auch aus Gold.
Viele Menschen sehen den digitalen Euro skeptisch,
weil sie digitale Überwachung durch den Staat befürchten.
Das ist auch erstmal nicht komplett aus der Luft gegriffen.
Beispiele aus China, Nigeria, Jamaika und Russland zeigen,
dass generelles Misstrauen gegenüber digitalen Zentralbankwährungen
nicht ganz unberechtigt sind.
Regierungen könnten potenziell mehr Macht gegenüber den Bürgern bekommen.
Man sieht ja auch, dass sobald
irgendwelche Gesetze da sind oder sobald irgendwelche Daten vorhanden sind,
dass sofort das Ganze ausgeweitet wird in Use Cases,
die ursprünglich sogar ausgeschlossen waren.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist immer noch diese Listen,
die bei Corona angefertigt wurden, wer irgendwo essen war.
Wo von Anfang an gesagt wurde, nein, die werden einzig und allein dafür verwendet,
um nachvollziehen zu können, wer mit wem Kontakt hatte,
wenn irgendwo Corona-Infektionskram ausbricht.
Dafür fand ich das auch sinnig.
Ich habe das auch immer gemacht.
Überall habe ich mich eingetragen.
Das ist doch sinnvoll, da weiß man Bescheid.
Aber es verging ein paar Wochen.
Dann kam die bayerische Polizei und hat gemeint,
ja, aber man könnte da uns doch auch Zugriff drauf geben.
Obwohl das von Anfang an ausgeschlossen wurde.
Also sobald was da ist,
wird es benutzt als in einer rein auf Bargeld ausgerichteten Finanzwelt.
Aber wird das Bargeld mit dem digitalen Euro abgeschafft?
Das ist in der EU gar nicht mal so einfach.
Der Vertrag über die Arbeitsweise der EU schützt das Bargeld nämlich.
Und diesen Vertrag können die Mitgliedsstaaten nur einstimmig ändern.
Das ist also ziemlich unwahrscheinlich.
Die EU-Kommission hat im Rahmen des digitalen Euros Vorschläge vorgelegt,
dass Bargeldschützen den Zugang dazu garantieren
und es als gesetzliches Zahlungsmittel verankern sollen.
Der digitale Euro soll also die bestehenden Zahlverfahren ergänzen, aber nicht ersetzen.
Das ist der Stand beim digitalen Euro.
Allerdings ist es so oder so noch ein weiter Weg,
bis wir wirklich mit dem digitalen Euro bezahlen können.
Denn seit November 2023 läuft erstmal die auf zwei Jahre angelegte Vorbereitungsphase.
Und auch danach wird es erstmal noch eine Pilotphase geben,
in der nach und nach Nutzungsmöglichkeiten und entsprechende APIs
für Banken sowie Präsenz und Online-Handel hinzukommen.
Selbst wenn alles wie am Schnürchen läuft,
können Bürger und Bürgerinnen der Euro-Länder flächendeckend kaum fort 2027 mit dem digitalen Euro.
2027? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Also, wenn dieses Projekt unter zehn Jahren dauern würde, würde ich mich schon sehr wundern.
Wie gesagt, ein publiker Fahrradweg dauert.
Über 20 Jahre.
Und das wäre jetzt schon das absolut schnellste Szenario.
Ganz wichtig noch, es ist noch nicht final entschieden,
ob der Euro-Raum den digitalen Euro überhaupt einführt.
Das entscheidet am Ende die Politik, also Mitgliedsstaaten und EU-Parlament.
Spricht zwar einiges dafür, aber ein Rückzieher ist immer noch denkbar.
Ja, und wie machen das andere Länder?
Die Eurozone ist bei weitem nicht alleine mit digitalen Währungsplänen.
Tatsächlich sind mehr als 110 Regierungen weltweit,
an über 160 Projekten dran.
Da sind nicht nur die Industrieländer dabei, sondern auch viele Entwicklungs- und Schwellenländer.
Die hoffen nämlich, dass sie mit einer digitalen Währung ihr eher dürftiges Netz an Bankfilialen und Geldautomaten ausbauen
und ihre Wirtschaft besser in den weltweiten Handel einbinden können.
Aber bis jetzt haben nur drei Länder ihre Digitalwährung eingeführt.
Jamaika, die Bahamas und Nigeria.
14 weitere Länder sind immerhin schon in der Pilotphase.
Ein Fazit.
In vielen Punkten ist der digitale Euro super interessant und hat auf jeden Fall viel Potenzial.
Weil klar, der digitale Zahlungsverkehr ist auf jeden Fall etwas wichtig.
Vieles von den Projekten hat immer Potenzial.
Aber wenn man sich so die letzten Sachen anguckt, dann bleibt da auch viel Potenzial auf der Strecke oftmals.
Wichtig ist also auf jeden Fall nachvollziehbar, dass die EU und die EZB das nicht komplett an nicht-europäische Unternehmen abgeben möchten,
sondern nur einen geringen Einfluss nehmen können.
Und die sich mal etwas flapsig ausgedrückt dumm und dusselig verdienen an der Explosion von Karten- und Smartphone-Zahlungen in Europa.
Die EZB und die EU-Kommission wollen sich aber auch mit einem eigenen Angebot absichern,
falls die digitalen Zentralbankwährungen von Staaten wie Russland oder China geopolitische Wirkung bekommen sollten.
Das Problem könnte aber vor allem in der Akzeptanz liegen.
Ganz ehrlich, es hat ja Jahre gedauert und eine Pandemie gebraucht.
Bis man in Deutschland einigermaßen flächendeckend mit Karte und Smartphone bezahlen konnte.
Also zum Beispiel beim Bäcker und vor allem auch, bis die meisten Banken da mitgemacht haben.
Ob dann die deutschen Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher in ein paar Jahren wieder etwas Neues benutzen wollen, wenn Apple Pay...
Das steht und fällt damit, wie einfach die Nutzung ist.
Und nachdem alle Endgeräte haben, die nicht von der EU kommen, glücklicherweise.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wie ein Handy aussehen würde, wenn es ein EU-Handy gäbe.
Ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach zu benutzen.
Wie sagen wir mal Apple Pay oder das Android-Gegengestück.
Und Einfachheit gewinnt bei sowas immer.
Google Pay, Paypal und so weiter noch mehr etabliert sind, ja, bin ich auch gespannt.
Also ich finde vor allem die Micropayment-Funktion interessant.
Also, dass man so im Vorbeigehen bezahlen kann, ohne dass es irgendwo Gebühren verursacht.
Die Frage ist für mich aber auch, wird der digitale Euro umständlicher, als sagen wir mal Apple Pay...
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Weil bei Apple Pay lege ich einfach mein Handy drauf und fertig.
Damit Apple einen Scheiß tun, dass das ähnlich easy wird.
Und mehr muss ich mich da nicht kümmern.
Beim digitalen Euro muss ich wahrscheinlich erstmal Geld vom Konto auf meinen digitalen Euro-Wallet...
Ja, das ist schon mal für den Arsch. Kannst vergessen.
Das klingt jetzt vielleicht nach einem nur mini-kleinen Mehraufwand.
Ne, das macht keiner.
Aber wenn ich mal so die Welt betrachte, dann sind das solche Kleinigkeiten, die darüber entscheiden, ob sich irgendwas durchsetzt.
Naja, vielleicht gibt es ja dann irgendwelche Automatik-Transferfunktionen, weiß man ja alles noch nicht.
Naja, ich wollte euch ja noch erklären, wie teuer Zahlungen mit Mastercard, Visa, Apple, Google Pay usw. so sind.
Wie viel Gebühren der Handel genau mit Kartenzahlungen und Handyzahlungen hat, kann man nicht zu 100% genau sagen.
Einen festen Wert gibt es halt nicht, weil das ist Verhandlungssache zwischen dem Händler und den Zahlungsabwicklern bzw. den Händlerbanken.
Man kann aber auf jeden Fall davon ausgehen, dass ein einzelner...
Hast du schon das Sideloading getestet? Ne.
Bisher war es ja eklig, weil du alle 7 Tage die App neu hast.
Ich habe das noch nicht wieder ausprobiert.
... mehr bezahlt als Aldi mit seinen ganzen Filialen.
Experten, die wir gefragt haben, setzen für Zahlungen mit Visa und Mastercard je nach Umsatzvolumen des Händlers ungefähr 0,7 bis 1,0% an,
oft noch plus monatlichen Grundgebühren und einem Sockelbetrag pro Zahlung, also zum Beispiel 9 Cent.
Ich zeige euch das mal an einem Beispiel, das für euch ja hoffentlich alle zwei Wochen absolut zum Alltag gehört, nämlich
der Kauf eines CT-Magazins.
Ich habe noch ein CT-Abo.
Kam erst letztens wieder eine.
Ja, genau die, die ihr da zeigt.
Das Ding ist, ich habe seit Ewigkeiten ein CT-Abo.
Und die letzten, keine Ahnung, 10 Jahre oder so, gefühlt lese ich die CT gar nicht mehr.
Die stapeln sich einfach.
Ich habe, ich habe letztens erst quasi hier einen kompletten Schrank voll an.
An alten CTs weggeschmissen.
Kauft ihr euch ein CT-Heft für 5,90 Euro mit Kreditkarte, beziehungsweise mit Apple oder Google Pay,
wo drin die Kreditkarte gespeichert ist, dann zahlt der Händler ungefähr 0,7% und 9 Cent Sockelbetrag.
Dann wären das insgesamt also 13 Cent bei 5,90 Euro.
Das ist schon nicht ohne.
Kauft ihr gleich 100 CT-Hefte, was ich euch übrigens sehr ans Herz legen würde, also ist der zu zahlende Betrag 590 Euro,
dann muss der Händler 4,22 Euro für die Zahlung blechen.
Nutzt ihr dagegen Girocard, also dieses deutsche System, was meist fälschlicherweise als EC-Karte bezeichnet wird,
dann müssen Händler deutlich weniger bezahlen, nämlich meist unter 0,25% und halt gegebenenfalls auch noch einen Sockelbetrag.
Ja, und das ist auch der Grund, dass einige Händler eben nur diese Girocard-Zahlung akzeptieren.
Ich hatte es aber auch schon umgedreht, als das eine nicht funktioniert hat, Mastercard aber funktioniert hat.
... sich eben ihre Marge nicht wegknabbern lassen wollen.
Kann ich aus Händlersicht verstehen, aus Kundensicht fuchst mich das aber ungemein, weil ich dann halt nicht mit dem Handy bezahlen kann.
Also eine Ausnahme gibt es, man kann Sparkassen-Girocards mit Apple Pay koppeln.
Richtig, das habe ich auch gemacht.
Aber das geht mit keiner anderen Bank und mit Google Pay gar nicht.
Und was man auch dazu sagen muss, Girocards kann man nur in Deutschland verwenden, im Ausland sind die nutzlos.
Übrigens, im E-Commerce sind die Zahlungen teurer.
Also 1,5 bis 2 Prozent, weil das Betrugsrisiko da höher ist.
Und American Express, Discover und Diners Club liegen in der Regel dann auch nochmal über Visa- und Mastercard-Kreditkarten.
Und es kassieren übrigens nicht nur die Kreditkartenbetreiber, die Dienstleister und die Händlerbanken,
sondern es muss auch die eigene Bank, also die Bank der Kartenkunden blechen.
Diese Gebühr heißt Interchange und die ist in der EU auf 0,2 Prozent bei Debitkarten und 0,3 Prozent bei Kreditkarten gedeckelt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was der Unterschied ist.
0,3 Prozent kassiert Apple Pay einen Teil.
Wie hoch der ist, kann und darf niemand sagen, weil Apple das den Unternehmen verbietet.
Google nimmt von den Banken nichts, dafür sichern die sich über die Nutzungsbedingungen beim Kunden weitgehend die Rechte an den Daten.
Ja, also ihr merkt schon, also so ein digitaler Euro mit mehr Datenschutz und weniger Gebühren, das hätte schon was.
Oder wie seht ihr das? Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und natürlich abonniert.
Ich gehe da mit, ich sage auch, das ist ein interessanter Ansatz.
Ich traue nur wieder den Leuten nicht zu, da eine ordentliche Umsetzung hinzubekommen.
Das ist wieder so ein weiteres IT-Fail-Projekt.
Dass da irgendwas zeitnah umgesetzt wird, kann man komplett vergessen.
Wie gesagt, Fahrradwege dauern über zwölf Jahre und sind immer noch in der Machbarkeitsstudienphase.
Also vor zwei, also in drei Jahren halte ich ja mal für ein Gerücht, ja.
Also wenn die das in zehn Jahren hinkriegen,
dann bin ich schon begeistert.
Ich bin unter 1,60 Meter, nice.
Und weiter, das wusste ich schon unbedingt mal wissen.
Guck mal, Fireship hat ein neues Video.
There's a fast new code editor in town.
Oh nein, lass mich raten, written in rust?
Was sonst, oder?
Die Krustentiere sind wieder am Schaden.
Lasst mal gucken, es geht nur 3 Minuten 57.
Die Fireship-Videos sind immer nice.
For nearly ten years now, Microsoft's VS Code has been the dominant text editor among the SoyDev community.
I use it on my Microsoft Windows machine to write Microsoft TypeScript code
with help from the latest AI models in Microsoft Copilot.
It installs my Microsoft NPM packages, pushes my code to Microsoft GitHub
and automatically deploys it to Microsoft Azure,
which I then admire from the Microsoft Edge browser.
But almost nothing in tech stays cool forever.
And today we'll look at a vast new open source code editor named ZED.
It is February 21st, 2024
and you're watching The Code Report.
A few weeks ago, a code editor named ZED, built in rust, was open sourced.
Wie, ich wusste, dass das irgendwas in rust sein muss, Mann!
It's built by the team behind the Adam Editor, which is a...
Ach, die sind das!
Das habe ich tatsächlich schon gelesen.
Ja.
I remember.
In fact, the very first video I made on this channel used Adam and not VS Code.
But wait a minute, who cares about a new editor, because...
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was wir Adam zu verdanken haben?
Adam Editor GitHub.
Wisst ihr, welches Piece of Software wir Adam zu verdanken haben?
Wann war das letzte Commit hier?
Zwei Jahre... ago.
Elektron, richtig.
Ja. Elektron.
Also, dass es heute so Sachen gibt wie Discord zum Beispiel,
haben wir Adam zu verdanken.
Da gibt es...
Also, wenn man es genau nimmt, haben wir die Existenz von Visual Studio Code Adam zu verdanken.
Ne, das ist so.
Das ist so. Was gibt es denn sonst noch für große Elektron-Apps?
Was fallen euch für Elektron-Apps ein?
Also, das erste, was mir einfällt, ist VS Code und Discord.
So an großen, ja.
Spotify, ja. Spotify könnte durchaus sein, ja.
Slack, richtig. Slack ist auch Elektron, ja.
Ne, Steam ist nicht Elektron.
Steam ist Embedded Chrome, aber schon ganz lange, schon länger seit das Elektron...
Teams, ja klar, Teams.
Wobei Teams ja mittlerweile nicht mehr so richtig Elektron ist.
Adam ist ein Text-Editor gewesen von GitHub.
Der hier.
Ja.
Daraus ist Elektron entstanden.
Also, Adam hat die Idee gehabt, einen Text-Editor zu...
Also, GitHub hatte eine...
Ja, Visual Studio Code ist auch auf Elektron-Basis.
GitHub hatte die Idee, einen Text-Editor zu erstellen auf JavaScript-Basis.
Und dazu haben sie halt was gebraucht,
mit dem du einen Text-Editor auf JavaScript-Basis machen kannst.
Und sie haben Node.js genommen und Chromium genommen
und die zusammengepackt und miteinander reden lassen.
Und geboren war Elektron.
Elektron hieß auch nicht von Anfang an Elektron, sondern Elektron hieß früher mal Atom Shell.
Da sieht man den...
Die Herkunft.
Das war schon 2015.
Übrigens, ich bin übelst pepega, ich hab den Zusammenhang zwischen, dass das Ding Atom Shell hieß
und jetzt heißt es Elektron, nie gecheckt.
Warum das so heißt.
Bis ich dann irgendwann mal bei genau dieser Suche mir aufgefallen ist,
dass um die Elektronenhülle bei Atomen...
Also, die Atomhülle und Elektron...
Ja.
Da hab ich lange Zeit nicht gecheckt.
Also, Atom haben wir Elektron zu verdanken.
Und damit so Sachen wie Discord zum Beispiel.
Aber jetzt gibt es ja...
Z.
Der ein bisschen aussieht...
Moment, das ist ja noch Elektron.
Ein Video, das ich auf diesem Kanal gemacht habe, verwendete Atom und nicht den S-Code.
Aber warte mal, wer kümmert sich um einen neuen Editor?
Weil ich wurde erzählt, dass Programmierung tot ist.
Eine Fähigkeit, die bald verwendet werden wird.
Wieso, ich dachte... Low-Code.
Ach nee, er kommt mit AI um die Ecke.
Es schwebt ja tatsächlich irgendwelchen Managern vor, so nach dem Motto,
demnächst macht, keine Ahnung, die Buchhaltung ihre eigene Anwendung mit irgendeiner Low-Code-Plattform.
Immer wenn ich solche Dinge höre, muss ich ganz hart kecken.
Wieso?
Und warte eigentlich nur, dass es Probleme gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das schon gefixt haben.
Ja, das stimmt.
Jetzt habe ich auch gehört, dass Chat-GPT gerade Schwachsinns-Antworten gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das schon gefixt haben.
Ja.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja
Insertion-Latency, Start-up-Time und Memory-Footprint
are all much better than the competition.
It achieves this performance by leveraging all of your CPU cores
along with the GPU using its own GPU-Framework.
It works like a video game where it rasterizes the entire window
to deliver 120 frames per second.
Okay, wichtig, wichtig.
120 FPS Code Editor. Nice!
Ich frage mich, wie die Leute das früher gemacht haben.
Aber ich finde, ihr versteht mich nicht falsch,
ich finde so eine Entwicklung extrem nice,
weil oftmals solche Projekte dafür sorgen,
dass auch die Technologien sich verbessern
in Mainstream-Produkten nach einer Weile.
Also oftmals fängt das an mit so kleinen Tests
und dann stellt man fest, oh, das ist ja cool
und irgendwann haben wir dann...
Wischel Studio Code in 120 FPS.
Wobei ich mich frage, warum das heute nicht auch schon geht.
Kannst du nicht einfach so schnell rendern lassen, wie irgendwie geht?
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, als musst du in einem Text-Editor so viel machen.
Themes to choose from and an integrated terminal.
It has a command palette and overall feels pretty similar to most other editors.
The company itself raised 10 million dollars last year
and has another feature geared more towards teams
where multiple people can collaborate in real time on the same code base.
Pretty cool.
And I imagine...
they'll have some kind of paid feature around this in the future.
But another unique feature is that the editor is also integrated with AI out of the box.
Das brauche ich halt nicht.
Es ist nice, ja, aber...
Also viel wichtiger ist es für mich,
dass es ordentliche Plugins gibt für alles, was ich verwenden will.
Und daran scheitert es ja letztendlich.
Das ist ja auch das, was Wischel Studio Code so gut macht.
Da hast du was wie Plattform-IO zum Beispiel für Microcontroller.
Du hast ein Svelte-Plugin.
Du hast für die React-Enjoyments...
Ja, ja, ein Plugin.
Du hast ein ekliges C++-Plugin.
Und ob es das in Z alles schon gibt, habe ich meine Zweifel.
Gucken wir doch mal.
Ah, das geht über irgendwelche Language-Server.
Gut.
Dann ist zumindest die Basics abgedeckt an Funktionen.
Warum braucht man so viel FPS-Input-Lag?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht genau, warum man das braucht.
Weil es geht.
Ein Multiplayer-Code-Editor.
Treesetter war irgendein Parser, gell?
Ja.
Wollen wir das auch mal installieren?
Wir gucken das Video fertig, dann gibt es das als Set.
Gibt es das schon als Package?
Äh.
Ah, ja, ja, hier, hier.
All of date.
Kann man das installieren?
Was, nur Mac?
Wirklich?
Ernsthaft?
Ja, dann ist es schon mal komplett dead.
Dann ist es komplett dead.
Wenn es es das Ganze nur gibt in...
Für Mac.
Nur Mac, Alter.
What the fuck?
Der hat auch mit Haarpflege viel zu tun, ne?
Ich hatte auch mal früher lange Haare, so.
Zu Heavy-Metal-Zeiten.
Das ist tatsächlich Metal.
Wo wir gerade...
Das ist tatsächlich...
Ja, das ist doch kacke.
Mac-only.
Wen juckt's?
Gibt es da noch alte Fotos?
Ja, gibt es.
Das ist schon ganz lange her.
Und du bringst einfach deine eigene OpenAI-API-Key rein
und bezahlst den Niveau der Token, die du nutzt.
Du kannst auch ein Stück Code einleiten
und dann der AI zu sagen, dass du es wiederfaktorierst.
Es schreibt den Code direkt vor deinen Augen wie Magie,
aber meistens gibt es eine sehr leere Erfahrung,
wenn du mit der AI in deinem Code arbeitest.
Aktuell ist es nur OpenAI,
aber in der Zukunft, ich denke,
werden sie auch weitere Modelle haben.
Wie Gemini's new...
Das ist halt das größte Ding bei Visual Studio Code.
Du hast Plugins für alles.
Und dadurch, dass die...
Und wenn du es nicht hast,
ist es easy, eins zu erstellen,
weil JavaScript...
Jetzt kommen bestimmt manche Leute und sagen,
ja, aber Max, in Emacs konnte man früher auch Plugins erstellen.
Ja, das konnte man.
Aber trotzdem gab es da nie so viele und so gute
wie bei Visual Studio Code.
Es gab ein paar gute, ja.
Das Problem an Emacs-Plugins ist Emacs an sich
und dass es Emacs-Lisp ist.
Genau.
Klammern ohne Ende.
Guckt euch mal den Source-Code an.
Von OrgMode zum Beispiel.
Und das ist ordentlich.
Das ist ordentliches Lisp noch.
Ich meine, seriously.
The fuck?
Und wie gesagt, das ist noch schönes Lisp.
Lesbar finde ich es trotzdem nicht.
They do plan on releasing a plugin API in the future,
but it'll be Rust-based
and likely never be as big
as the JavaScript-based VS Code.
But by far the biggest limitation as of today
is that it's only available on Mac OS.
That's a big disappointment for a lot of people,
but they do plan on supporting Linux and Windows in the future
as long as they find a viable business model first.
So it may not be a VS Code,
but it may be a VS Code killer as of today,
but it does have the potential to get there,
assuming that programming is still a thing done by humans
in the next few years.
This has been The Code Report.
Thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one.
So.
Lass uns doch mal kurz schauen.
Hat doch grad einer ein Issue gepostet.
Rose to Linux.
Ja gut.
Wendy, das wundert mich auch nicht,
dass es schwierig ist, das auf Linux zu portieren,
weil wir sehen ja hier unten,
die machen Low-Level-Kram.
Mit irgendwelchen Shader-Sachen und Metal auf Mac OS.
Das heißt, die brauchen auch einen Low-Level-Render-Kram für Linux.
Und dann hast du wieder das Problem unter Linux,
wie machst du das gescheit?
Es muss ja eigentlich,
es muss ja irgendein Vulkan Open oder OpenGL,
wahrscheinlich Vulkan-Renderer werden.
Wie hieß denn dieser,
habt ihr noch, wisst ihr noch, wie das hieß?
AMD hatte doch mal in Battlefield 4
so eine Alternative zu DirectX.
Wie hießen das nochmal?
Mantle hieß das, nicht Metal.
Mantle.
Das ist das, was dann später auch ein bisschen
in Vulkan und so mit aufgegangen ist, oder?
Weil Vulkan ist ja quasi von den OpenGL-Leuten
das neue Zeug.
Ich glaube, Mantle ist da ein bisschen mit drin aufgegangen.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht,
dass sie sich hauptsächlich eben ums UI dreht,
was du unter Linux supporten musst.
Fix Bugs and make Z good.
Schöne Roadmap.
Ja, so habe ich das auch im Hinterkopf.
Z-Game.
Ich habe Hunger.
Nudeln mit Lachs?
Dem Fiat Champ,
dem geht es genauso gut wie vor zwei Jahren,
weil das letzte Comet ist, glaube ich,
vom Dezember 2022.
Ja, eineinhalb Jahren, ein Jahr.
Habe ich schon gesehen.
Wir haben ja gar nichts rewritet.
Wir haben ein Webinterface rumgebastelt.
Wird der Fiat Champ vor dem Radweg fertig?
Naja, fertig in Form von es funktioniert,
ist er ja schon.
Aber in Form von neue Sachen unterstützen
und das alles immer verbessern,
weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich wird der Radweg vorher fertig.
Wobei der auch nicht fertig wird.
Ich glaube, der Fiat Champ wird vor dem Radweg fertig.
Was ist der Fiat Champ?
Das ist ein Home Assistant Addon,
was ich gebaut habe,
wo du...
Warum sieht denn die Seite eigentlich so procken aus gerade wieder?
Ah, okay, nice.
Wo du von deinem Elektroauto
Daten abrufen kannst
und in deine Heimautomatisierung packen kannst.
Ein Ticket könntest du ja mal machen.
Und dann machen wir Daily Scrum hier im Stream.
Theoretisch geht es auch für Fiat Jeep, Ram, Dodge und Alfa Romeo.
In der Theorie.
Work in Progress, genau.
Zu wenig Emojis in der Readme.
Ich finde, das muss so sein.
Ich habe sogar einen Pull Request angenommen,
der meine Readme emojified hat.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, von wem das kam,
aber irgendjemand...
Oder Max, hast du das nicht sogar gemacht?
Irgendjemand hat meine Readme emojified.
Und das muss sein.
Wir hatten eindeutig zu wenige Emojis in der Readme.
Work in Progress steht auch sogar da.
Was ist der Ubu-Translator?
Oh, guck mal.
Nudeln mit Lachs sind weg.
Gib doch ab, wenn du da keine Lust drauf hast.
Ja, weil da auch so viele Leute Bock drauf haben, gell?
Das ist wohl wahr.
Da fehlen einige Kack-Ws und Kackles und sonst was.
Das stimmt schon.
Ich glaube, die Readme muss dringend
ver-Twitch-emotified werden.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema Texteditor sind.
Kann Emacs für Linux eigentlich Emojis mittlerweile sein?
Ich glaube, immer noch nicht.
Nicht, dass ich jemals wieder Emacs verwenden möchte,
aber das war so eines der Dinger, wo man echt gemerkt hat,
dass das Ding rückständig als Fuck ist.
Ja, nee, das von uns schon mal nicht.
Ja, siehste, der benutzt WSL.
Ja, das ist...
Siehste, es gibt immer noch keine Emojis für Emacs.
Das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Das heißt, setzt PNGs da drinnen.
Ist halt Schrott, ne?
Wenn solche Sachen auch jahrelang später noch nicht unterschrieben werden.
Ah, bei mir ist auch eine ganze Weile her und ich sehe es auch nicht ein.
Works Kappa.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen Fail, oder?
Das hört sich so an wie...
Ja, funktioniert.
Haha, she baited.
Leute, ich hab Hunger. Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Was ist das da oben?
Ach, das ist Bing AI oder sowas, ne?
Esk...
Jaja, nervt nicht.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Heute gibt's kein Lachs mit Nudeln.
Heute gibt es Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
Ohne Lachs.
Lachsge...
Tomatensoos, wie man hier auf hessisch sagt.
Soos.
Nachher noch mal, da...
Kommt drauf an, ob MMO Geisel grindt oder nicht.
Gibt es eine gute Quelle, um C-Sharp zu lernen?
Ja.
Für die Basics.
Aber nur für die absoluten Basics kann ich dir immer noch von...
Ähm...
Ich würde es 2012 empfehlen.
Aber nur für die Basics.
Also quasi nur bis...
Bis maximal...
16.
Weil das ist alt und bezieht sich auch noch auf das .NET Framework.
Aber gerade am Anfang so die grundlegenden Sachen, die sind schon ganz okay.
Und das Buch ist auf Deutsch.
Das mögen ja viele in ihrer Native.
Ansonsten...
Hat Microsoft selbst auch ein paar ganz gute Tutorials.
Ja. Und es gibt sicherlich...
Auch ein paar Up-to-Date...
Bücher.
Und Kurse.
Aber da weiß ich nicht welche gut sind.
Weil...
Ich hab keinen C-Sharp-Kurs gebucht bisher.
Ja das liest sich doch gut hier.
.NET 8.
Das ist auch halbwegs aktuell.
Also was heißt halbwegs?
Es ist aktuell weil .NET 8 ist das Aktuelle.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit .NET Framework.
Das ist was ganz anderes.
Keine Ahnung.
Ne.
Also ich benutze Visual Studio Code für Frontend Sachen.
Und ja für Sachen wo es gut ist.
Weil es gute Plugins gibt.
Wie Plattform I.O.
Für ESP32 Microcontroller.
Ansonsten verwende ich die Jetbrain IDS.
Jetbrains.
Heißt die eigentlich Jetbrain?
Hat mehr als ein Gehirn.
Multiple 5 Head.
Ich geh was essen Leute.
Wir hören uns. Bis dann. Machts gut.
Ciao.